in the middle of a press conference Joe
Biden cut it short saying he had to go
to the Situation Room to deal with
something and that something is
reportedly Iran striking numerous US
military bases in Iraq and Syria we've
got reporting now from Israel that Iran
was involved in the attacks that we saw
from Hamas the US is deploying the fad
missile system into the region and many
journalists note that Hezbollah and
Hamas do not have ballistic missiles the
Thad system is Miss I believe it's
missile defense system it's for uh uh
stopping and intercepting it's kind of
like the Iron Dome so it looks like we
are gearing up for war with Iran call it
World War III whatever trending on
Twitter on X World War I we'll talk
about this and a lot of stories in this
area it looks like we're gearing up for
global war or a lot of news reports
coming out that China is preparing for
the same thing and it looks like whether
anyone wants it to or not and I assume
there are a lot of people who want it to
this is where we're headed before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.net censored membersonly shows
Monday through Thursday on
timcast.net
Para hey nice to meet you thanks for
having me yeah who are you what do you
do I like to consider myself like an
America First Crusader for Christ um I
work with a number of campaigns and
legislators throughout the country to
kind of invoke and push forward the
americ first agenda um I joined the army
right out of high school finished that
up and uh now I'm just focused on you
know doing what I can uh from my from
social media and journalism and just
working with some of these folks to
really you know enact the America First
agenda right on well thanks for hang
should be fun we got Hannah Clair brimo
hanging out hi I'm Hannah Clair brimo
I'm a writer for
timcast.net uh alongside the post
millennial because liby's here hey
thanks Hannah CLA I'm Libby emmans I'm
filling in for I again uh which is
awesome I'm the editorinchief of the
post-millennial and human events.com
and I am surge.com we miss you in come
back uh let's get started Tim here's the
story from Sky News President Joe Biden
Cuts press conference short as White
House confirms Iran actively
facilitating some attacks on US military
bases in Iraq and Syria I just love the
the language how it's so like passive
and
Confused Iran actively facilitating some
attacks okay look is Iran attacking the
us or not I think the issue is they want
to seed the information that's how it
usually happens they want to gear us up
for the moment when they announc troops
are going to be deployed specifically to
fight with Iran we've already seen
members of of Congress say they're
drafting an authorization for use of
military force against Iran and their
proxies whatever proxies means and it
seems like this is going to Bubble Up to
World War I on Twitter World War I is
trending here's the clip I'm going to
play this clip for you it's it's it's
quite simple it's only a few seconds
long and when uh Malcolm Flex has it
Biden cuts his speech short as the
attacks are happening can't confirm if
it's casual not here we go we got the
sound right I apologize I have to go to
the situation with another issue I have
to deal with but thank you thank you
thank you so that's it it's it's it's
rather uneventful other than to say in
the middle of a press conference he
announced he was going to have to go to
the situation room because uh we've got
these uh this report Malcolm Flex is
tweeting groups with ties to the Iranian
militias claim they've attacked with
rockets three bases in Northeast Syria
al- Omar Al tan and Al shadadi could be
a tell as far as where Iran uh uh and
probably Iran loyal militant states in
the area
stand okay well I hope you're already
for uh World War II and uh how how you
doing I learned that if you have taken
anti-press or anti-anxiety medication in
the last uh over the last 12 months or
for a cumulative 36 months in the last
couple years you can't be drafted so I
think a lot of women are not going to uh
be drafted as we head into World War I
so I hope you're ready jenz especially
there's so much big farm is going to
save the day right well it is our great
hope and savior uh what would we do
without big Pharma that's really
interesting because women don't get Dr
drafted anyway mhm women don't have to
register for Selective Service no they
don't only if you're a man who's dressed
like a woman then you have to register
for Selective Service they hav gotten
around that loophole yet which is kind
of funny uh yeah well because Biden came
there was a report last year that um the
Biden Administration was saying that uh
trans women do have to register for a
selective
service so all you draft Dodgers that
are buying skirts right now don't worry
it's not going to work yeah just get on
the SSRI instead well it's funny because
uh I there was this poll that came out
about the Israel Israel Palestine
conflict and I guess 18 to 24
overwhelmingly are in favor of Palestine
and Hamas and I say and Hamas because I
am not trying to say they're the same
thing I'm actually drawing the
distinction many of these leftists are
cheering on Hamas explicitly that's what
I'm trying to point out you know and
it's because of that the the US is
getting its ever so desperate casses
belly uh with for Iran the the US uh
military-- industrial complex deep State
whatever has wanted war with Iran the
entire time I've been alive all right
and so now because of this fight you
know Hamas going into Israel killing all
these civilians Israel's released
footage it's horrifying footage man some
of it's only been described some of it
there is video they released I watched
some of it it's crazy and now this is
the funny thing the US likes to
do Hamas attacks Israel and so all of a
sudden they're like it you mean Iran we
have to go to war with Iran like no no
no we're talking about Hamas you mean so
so Iran we're going to go we're invading
Iran all right let's send the troops to
Iran it's like what okay I guess but now
they're basically saying that all of
this is actually Iran Iran's the one
funding it Iran's the one planning it
it's like okay well then fine I guess
we're going to World War II well Iran
was reported by The Wall Street Journal
to have been in a meeting with Hamas and
Hezbollah just uh the Monday before the
attack saying that um it it was reported
that Iran greenlit the attack at that
point and then Iran denied it later but
um Iran has been backing Hamas for a
very long time Iran has been backing
Hamas since like Israel kicked out a
bunch of terrorists and sent them to
Lebanon where they got trained by
Hezbollah and the uh what is it the
Iranian guard what are they called I
forget but um the igf the igf yeah the
igf and they were getting trained so
Hamas got trained by
Hezbollah and the igf in Lebanon before
they um became Hamas in the late ' 80s
this would mean that Russia should be
declaring war in the United States
explicitly um perhaps Ukrainian forces
are funded armored trained by us and EU
forces and if the argument from the
United States is that we have to go to
war with Iran because they've trained
Hamas then Russia would need to declare
war in the United States right this this
argument is you know have your cake and
eat it too yeah it's it's the US is
version of it's okay when we do it I
mean exactly it's ridiculous I mean I
think part of it is that we always knew
there was very slim chance that this
wouldn't expand regionally that other
countries nearby would get involved and
I think you're right with this headline
they're trying to sort of preemptively
set up the argument for why America
needs to get involved in this war which
uh I just don't think is necessarily the
beste scenario for anyone and I
understand that we have uh allies we
have relationships diplomatic with with
Israel and and everyone else in the
region on the other hand we create all
of these problems and then we say oh
well don't worry we'll come fix it I
don't know pron did you do anything uh
exciting when you were in the Army uh no
no I didn't uh right when I joined
really the coid pandemic hit and they
enforced the co vaccine and that's kind
of why I'm out now wow yeah so no I
didn't get to do much what was your like
what was your role was your job 88 Mike
I was actually going to do green to Gold
where I could enlist to become a Jag
officer that's what the whole plan was
until it got kind of sidestepped by the
vaccine oh wow well here we are I'm not
I I wonder that's actually a really
interesting point you bring up because
we're talking about the draft too but
how many good men and women in uniform
left over the the the coid vaccination
and the bigger picture how how depleted
or how how how how far behind are we in
terms of recruitment goals not just
because of the vaccine but because of
wokeness and politics in general I guess
the conspiracy theory is the reason the
US is is allowing all these people to
cross the border into the country is
that they're going to offer up
citizenship to be Frontline infantry or
something which you know I don't know if
that's effective but I do kind of know
anybody who's played any one of these
strategy Video Games like World of
Warcraft or Starcraft or whatever you
just mass-produced the lowest quality
fighter and just nonstop send them wave
after wave if your enemies you win so
like you can have all the nukes all the
Jets all the satellites you want but if
your ground Army is bigger you win and
you know you're willingness to sacrifice
them but in that capacity the US has
technology but they don't have people
sure no they don't and the the thing
about military recruitment goals is that
we've been behind for a long time so
there are people who left like you're
saying because of uh the co vaccine
there are now also people who will not
enlist because of the co vaccine and so
on top of the issues that we're already
having with a population that is not
qualified to be a part of the military
those who are willing to enlist and who
will enlist is it's just this extremely
small margin I don't like the idea that
we would just be like oh well you came
here illegally but to give you
citizenship will let you enlist in the
Army I think that's not a logical
justification but if you're about to say
things are very desperate we need boots
on the ground you're sort of creating a
worst case scenario and then delivering
this solution that is imperfect in of
itself well that's kind of the strategy
they use like recruiters use to bring
people into the military uh I know my
recruiters at least would it's kind of
like a running joke on Tik Tok too where
people will go to like a Home Depot and
pick up illegals to join the military
and they'll offer them you know
citizenship so they'll join but just in
my personal experience um all the good
folks all the people who you know were
meant to be in the military there wasn't
a lot of them left and I know that
during my basic training in uh AIT which
is like Advanced Training for your job
um we had
people the the treatment of peoples and
their standards was unbelievable uh
women were you know like we had some
people in there that were like 5'2
couldn't carry load for themselves we
would go on Ruck marches that were
really 12 mil long and they would end up
falling out and they would get put in a
truck and get driven back and or they
couldn't shoot what you were supposed to
shoot what the standard was and they
would pass them anyway why would they
pass them anyway because they have to
fill these spots creating cannon fodder
basically this is the other thing that's
happening is that recruitment all of the
numbers are actually off from what I
know from people who are inlisted right
now is that they are using like they are
you shifting data to pad their numbers
because they are so far behind in in
recruitment goals I mean it's not good
but once you get into the army they need
to keep you there so the what I've heard
from a lot of people and this goes back
well before the culture War stuff that
in basic training the men like your your
the the the clothes they give you what
the pts is that what they're called
filthy and dirty as you're like crawling
through the mud you don't watch them you
take them off you wake up you eat as
fast as you can you get back to it the
women would cry complain sit down refuse
to walk any further cuz it hurts too
much and then be told don't worry it's
fine like you mentioned get truck to
drive the rest of the way they couldn't
carry anything they had they they they
were mandated to be able to get showers
and clean clothes every day and the
argument was medical women have medical
reasons where they're required to have
clean clothes and so the men are being
like thrown into the into the muck and
told figure it out and the women are are
being given this this like hospital
fourstar treatment these are all reasons
that I never would have joined the
military well and they also I like
showers and clean clothes no no you get
them women get them men don't that's
that's ridicul they got complacent with
like the low standards a lot of the
girls and they would literally walk the
two mile runs well what what I was told
is that if they tell the women you can't
have a shower it's discrimination based
on sex because women have special needs
and so they have to get showers and then
they shouldn't be allowed to join the
military but if you and if and if they
hold the women at the same standards as
the men well that's sexist because men
and women are different even though now
the argument is that men and women
aren't different if you look at the uh
which is it the bowo decision if you
look at the bck decision it's sexual
discrimination to not give the men
showers
yeah but to give the women showers it
would that would be discri that's
discriminatory well the point is
whenever everybody gets showers on the
battlefield come on Tim anything that
doesn't benefit the left is
discrimination until it benefits them
then it's balc so like if the if you say
they'll come out they'll say men and
women are the same therefore you know
trans people should be in women's sports
everyone should be equal and then you go
okay military training equality that's
not fair men and women are different
women can't care as much as men so they
get special treatments you just met men
women weren't different I saying they're
different so the issue is the left
simultaneously argues both positions
this why I often say there's no morality
on the left there is none the left does
not have a moral position they have a
give me power so in the military women
don't run not all of them you know some
women do but right you know so so this
this an interesting point about where
we're currently at in recruitment goals
it's probably worse than we realize the
military is probably a whole bunch of
like 22y old women with two moms yeah I
think it's that's in their advertising
yeah they'll throw a bonus at you
$20,000 to join but their standards are
ridic and I even had a girl in front of
me on one March specifically and she was
crying because the the load was too much
for her to carry she was again like 5
foot2 so I tried to like lift her Bru
sack up with my hands the whole way
there but it's like you can't have that
kind of like situation on the
battlefield you know and so I just think
it's kind of sad that that's where we've
gotten to as a country I've heard
arguments before that they need to
revisit some of their standards like
this thing about anxiety medication
right like if you have taken anxiety
medication during these parameters
you're disqualified for military service
so it means that some people just don't
report it or you know I've heard a lot
of um Special Forces people say I just
lied I lied my way through it because I
wanted really badly to make it and I am
qualified other than these sort of you
know rules they felt were arbitrary but
in some cases you know the idea of being
battle ready is very important and I
think we saw this with you know letting
women in the military the physical
standard which they expected to to meet
has to be lowered because women are
different biologically and
physiologically than men and so
ultimately in pursuit of what we think
is best at home are we actually putting
people in Foreign Fields in a battle
ready situation where the people around
them can protect them I just don't think
so well and also that shouldn't really
be what's going on in a battlefield
everyone should be there to do their
best and not need to be protected by
their peers the other thing though is
like I think it's normal to have people
looking out for each other when out for
each other but like you can't look out
for someone who can't look out for you
sure you know like if the 5 foot2 woman
who can't carry her own pack like how's
she going to look after Preston she's
not that's the problem so you're not
allowed to have taken ssris and anxiety
medication for a certain period of time
but you are allowed to be taking cross-
seex hormones no no no no no no no no no
no they give you the cross- seex
hormones oh they give you those of
course up that's like your rations you
know rations got it let's jump to this
from The New York Times us SS more
missile defense systems to Middle East I
love this headline because they don't
want to actually uh give you the
headline that explains we're about to go
to World War I the latest deployment is
in response to Growing threats from Iran
and its allies in the region President
Biden has warned Iran to not join the
war against Hamas why would Iran join a
war against Hamas see the New York Times
phrases these things in very interesting
ways so they're sending a Thad
battery which is um I don't know if they
what it stands for it's uh something
high altitude aerial defense or
something like this I forgot what the
first one is you sending Thad battery
and additional Patriot battalions to
have its most powerful weapons against
missiles to the region in a statement
Sunday blah blah blah they're going to
be sending a lot more and we have this
from Bloomberg us vows to hold Iran
responsible for attacks on troops in mid
East Pentagon spokesman places blame
even without a direct order us is moving
more forces weapons and ships to the
region so we already had
19,000 we're moving up to 21,000 active
Personnel in the region I think six uh
well Washington Post reported 4,000
Marines and sailors with 2,000 troops I
guess more Marines so I don't know what
how many of those individuals are
specifically for uh uh ground combat M
says the US rammed up its retoric toward
Iran saying it would hold tan
accountable for drone and Rocket attacks
on US troops by its proxies in the
Middle East even as Washington tries to
avert a r wider Regional War they keep
saying that does is Washington actually
trying to avert anything no I don't
think so F like Nikki that are just you
know just they just want us to go to war
they've got rathon in their closet and
we shouldn't be involved at all you know
Biden shouldn't be making statements it
and and really any Republican who calls
himself America First should not be
advocating for any action whatsoever in
the Middle East we have our own problems
here we don't need to worry about abroad
uh we've got veterans killing themselves
I think it's 16 a day young men killing
themselves at astronomical rates more
than any other demographic in the
country we don't need to be over there
and especially in a situation where
you've got two sides of it where both
are committing atrocity and I think most
people just want peace but even if you
say you want peace if you say you want a
ceasefire folks like Ben Shapiro will
say that you're a pro terrorist and so
it's really unfortunate and uh if you're
going to be America First you cannot be
Pro involvement in the Middle East at
all so that is terminal high altitude
area defense formerly known as theater
high altitude area defense so that's
what it stands for I remember when I was
in South Korea they had a bunch of
people protesting said saying no Thad
and the argument was that the US was
going to deploy the Thad system in to be
able to respond to uh North Korea North
Korean ballistic missile attacks but as
as I mentioned in the earlier segment
many journalists are saying Hezbollah
and Hamas don't have this so the US is
just gearing up for war with Iran I
think a lot of these news stories a lot
of them are
intentionally they're they're seeding
they're a little bit of spice in the
news to be like get you used to it war
with Iran War with Iran that way when
something happens cuz now we've got
conversations about sleeper cells Hamas
sleeper cells the United States the US
is trying to connect Hamas to Iran as
much as they can because of what just
happened in Israel now we've got reports
Kevin McCarthy Ronda Sanz have been
warning about this they're saying Hamas
has sent sleeper cells to the southern
border the next thing that happens is
some kind of false flag or just an
outright attack from Hamas and then they
say see that was a run yeah I think
ultimately that is the direction I also
think it's very difficult for the
American people to keep up with with all
of the moving Parts there are so many
moving Parts there so many moving parts
and they they share a complicated
intertwined Regional history that we
just are blind to in a lot of ways we
don't really know it we know history and
we know you well but what's interesting
though and this is some research I was
doing uh over the weekend actually and
last week um the history that we know of
Israel in the Middle East is given to us
primarily and given to our students by
textbooks and those textbooks were um
created most of them after 911 at this
point and they were heavily influenced
by like the center for Islamic education
that talked to the Publishers and the
textbook companies and made sure to have
very positive views of Islam and very
negative views of Judaism and
Christianity so when you see all of
these high school students staging
walkouts of like you know saying like uh
you know free Palestine and like stand
with Gaza and all of this stuff they
have been taught that in their history
classrooms that is what they have
learned directly and they have learned
that directly um because that's you know
that's within the text in the textbooks
these are textbooks that were adopted in
California and because California is
such a huge market for educational
materials once it's in those textbooks
that's what's disseminated across the
rest of the country it downplays Jihad
it downplays the concept of from The
River To The Sea which is the
eradication of Israel it downplays
Sharia law as something that just means
get closer to God it downplays the
modesty laws and all of that stuff I did
like a I was reading in these textbooks
um it even downplays the uh Islamic
conquest and it says that Islam spread
it doesn't say that Islam not not saying
it's spread by the sword it doesn't say
that it's spread by the water it just
naturally to the sword and it also says
like that because that it's part of
Islam that you can't convert people on
purpose and so therefore it's peaceful
and it lives it lives uh Islam lives in
harmony with other religions without
actually mentioning the the horrifying
Wars the like yeah you know all of that
stuff what the cultural implications are
I mean there's a story right now about
this 16-year-old girl yeah we covered
that today at human events she was a a
beaten because over she wasn't wearing
her her job correctly I believe and she
she's in AET draged from a train right
she's she's in a vegetative state she I
assume will not make it which is
extremely tragic but in America we get
to say like oh it's just a different
culture we don't know what it's like
there it's it's gross we we would not
let this happen here I hope uh but we do
let it happen here I mean we have
there's honor killings in the US yeah
there are but we don't talk about them
yes but on while there are many stories
like that there are women being
victimized and beaten in the streets and
men as crime is running rampant we're
now seeing like CVS rid Walgreens and
all these stores 1,500 stores are
closing over the over the rampant crime
so when we talk about oh it's so awful
this woman didn't wear her job and and
she was beaten you're absolutely right
it's horrible and then we have the story
of the woman on the train in
Philadelphia who was raped and everyone
just watched it happen right then you
have the story of the guy in New York
City who saw the dude threatening the
lives of people on the train and said I
got to stop this guy with three two
other dudes and then they tried to lock
him up yeah they're still trying to lock
him up they're still trying to lock him
up yeah they're we like we would never
let it happen here and here's a guy who
tried to save the lives of people on the
train and one woman said that man saved
our lives and the police are locking
them up in jail so we got those problems
I don't think is that we don't let bad
things happen here it's just the
specific modest laws don't exist here
the same way except when they're
enforced culturally by we got the other
direction I know this is the problem I
mean it's like we we have the mirror
image to the Iran problem Iran's problem
is they're beating women for not wearing
a job they shouldn't be doing that and
then and they they kill this young woman
there's protests and then United States
the inverse where they're putting these
lwd and lascivious books in schools and
we're like man where's the middle ground
like let women wear you know sexy
clothes but don't give kids these books
with graphic material in and it's weird
because the same Progressive that are
saying yes put those books in school are
the same ones chanting in favor of EX
right right they would be like the first
ones on the Wallas had anything to say
about they could never survive in this
this culture they're the left tried
arguing this a long time ago that Trump
supporters had a lot in common with like
Al-Qaeda and like Muslim terrorists or
whatever like dude if Hamas did come
over here and it was just like some some
like regular Palestinian guy on a street
corner and he started expressing his
opinions on lgbtq stuff and wokeness a
lot of conservatives would be like I
completely agree with those positions
then of course the guy would say
something like throw him off a roof or
whatever something horrifying and the
Trump support would be like yo bro
what's wrong with you that's crazy
that's like way too far for us but so
many of these leftwing activists are
cheering for a group that as you all
mentioned would either lock them up for
10 years at the law in in Gaza being gay
is a 10-year prison sentence or
something substantially worse mhm yeah I
think I think a lot of them are
definitely uneducated on you know what
goes on in Palestine but I do understand
some of their gripes and I think that
you know you talk about the textbook
things I've heard reports of textbooks
being infiltrated with Zionist uh you
know certain angles and I'm Jewish and
you know I don't want that I want my you
know students in my country learning you
know real truth and you know not you
know that's tampered with by some
special interest and so and I think
that's why a lot of Americans especially
Christian Americans are kind of
entranced with the fact that we must go
to war we must go defend Israel and
listen I I want there to be peace more
than anyone but I don't think we should
get involved with a conflict at all
that's foreign I think we should be
focusing on our issues here like the guy
in the subway and um and I and I just
think that Americans are so funny as at
least Christian Americans and especially
those who call themselves conservatives
when they say let's not go to Ukraine
quit sending my lunch money to Ukraine
and then the second Israel gets attacked
they want to send the kitchen well
Israel is a really longstanding Ally I
and I get that I get that but when that
long-standing Ally is committing war
crimes Israel was attacked right they
were attacked and that shouldn't have
happened and I think that it's under
questionable circumstances as well
because even Charlie Kirk pointed out
that uh when it happened there was a
seven-hour stop order ordered by
Netanyahu he didn't say that
definitively though right in which he
was attacked right after too but Charlie
said I wonder if it if someone gave a
stand on order cuz how did they not know
this well in in Egypt warned them
apparently too but also yeah but Egypt
said something big might happen which is
not a warning of anything it's not it's
not we don't we don't know what the
specific intelligence it was and I also
think it it is tough because there is
you you you you can draw a benefit to
Netanyahu specifically uh and the
stability of of Israel from the crisis a
unifying crisis we saw this with the
project for a New American Century back
in like 2001 or whatever a new Pearl
Harbor would rally the American people
but I don't think that creates a
circumstance in which the simple
solution is Israel knew it was going to
happen and let it happen because the
damage and Devastation to Israel is
1,000 times greater than whatever they
they were they were experiencing yeah
and I don't think it's a I think it's
definitely a corruption issue and that
was what Netanyahu was like under
investigation for in the first place he
was about to he was under indictment and
he was about to face trial for it and a
war happens to happen right in his
backyard right when he needed it to and
I just think it's a little bit odd and I
think that when you have mosad which is
one of the world's most advanced
intelligence agencies how did they not
pick up that their most uh you know
angered neighbor it was not going to
attack them I just don't buy it I don't
buy it but I don't see any evidence to
the contrary either and and I think the
issue with the is the issue I take with
it is I can tell you you know because I
was talking earlier about Cassandra
Fairbanks a bunch of bunch of
conservatives are really angry they're
very pro-israel and I'm like dude the
the the uh uh this company and the work
that I do is not pred predicated upon
the history of Gaza and Israel right and
so what ends up happening is you have
these people who for for some reason
have a large portion of their identity
rooted in which side is correct and
which side is wrong and so they'll come
out and they'll assert one side has you
know it's funny because they're like you
know it's it's historically Palestine
therefore is you know Israel is the
occupying force and then the other
people are like it was Judea and it was
like Jerusalem the Holy Land are you
crazy and I'm just like I got I can tell
you it's not America and yeah I'm not
from there that's my there have been
there's been violence and conflict over
this region for a really long time
including in recent years prior to
October 7th I'm not saying that Israel
shouldn't be able to defend itself of
course it should on the other hand
similarly to the conflict that's been
ongoing between Russia and Ukraine for a
long time is this in the Americans
American people's best interest to wait
into a war which we have very little
cultural understanding of and at the
same time make worse like Joe Biden
saying yes Gaza I will give you money
also Israel I'll send some troops in we
don't know what side we're going to be
on and ultimately we're not going to
make anyone happy we're only going to
ask I certain what side we're going to
be on I certainly hope we're going to be
on the side of our allies our allies are
committing war crimes what war crimes
are they committing well if you're
seeing the reports of white phosphorus
being uh in so you're taking hamas's
word no no no no but I'm taking reports
on the ground I you know I'm Jewish and
I just don't want anyone I don't want
atrocity being conducted against anybody
I don't want any more Israeli lives to
be uh taken I don't want any more
Palestinian lives to be taken especially
innocent children that we're seeing and
so many times I'm saying this online and
people are saying oh so you're Pro Hamas
or you know you're Pro syp sympathizer
for terrorist no not at all but I don't
want I don't want any Innocents to die
and I'm seeing white phosphorus being
rained down and one in 20 buildings in
Gaza is are leveled and you you're
seeing more bombs being dropped on Gaza
than were dropped in the entire first
year in the Afghanistan war and so I and
those are war crimes okay cuz when you
have War crime though what does that
mean ctive punishment defined by the
Geneva Convention is to punish an entire
group of people innocent people for the
crimes of especially this a terror group
it's the government though Hamas was
elected to lead the government but there
hasn't been a fair election in a decade
but the I think the we we pulled this up
too the recent surveys show that 51% of
people in Gaza support Hamas and so yeah
I'm not going to blame the civilians
there's a lot of really uh awful videos
that are coming out but I'll tell you
exactly where I'm at uh I don't know
anything about the region for the most
part I mean obviously I do know a bit
about the region but uh I have no vested
interest in the outcome in the region I
I am not here to be like the history of
Israel or Israel this Israel that or
Palestine this Palestine that I can tell
you that on October 7th a horrifying
terror attack occurred in which Hamas
tore through the fences went in and
started massacring civilians Israel's
released some of this footage we got a
bunch of this footage and then what I
end up hearing from people is yeah well
I bet Israel knew and I'm like how did
we shift from we quite literally have
video of civilians being gunned down in
their car and people burning down homes
and children being killed and the
response immediately is yeah but I bet
net now knew about it because he was
doing it to benefit himself and it's
like no no no no no no no no we are so
far from that conversation the
conversation is right now Israel was
attacked innocent civilians were killed
uh uh Max Blumenthal came on and said
Hamas targeted the civilians because
it's opportunistic for them it's part of
their Doctrine to Target civilians to
use as as bargaining chips against
Israel and then after that is the
beginning and opening premise I have
people complaining about Israel and I'm
like yeah you know yeah Israel's
probably done doing a lot of bad stuff
it's it's it's this is what happens when
you declare war on someone Hamas
declared war on Israel Israel is the
PowerHouse with the fourth most powerful
Army so they say with support from
Western powers and Hamas decided to
declare war now a lot of people then go
yeah well you know it's an open air
prison and blah blah blah I'm like that
you lost me already I am not Israel I am
not Palestine I am the United States of
America I am an individual here and I
can't tell you about the history of the
region I can tell you if they did not
tear down those fences stor in and
Massacre a thousand plus civilians there
would not be bombings in Gaza that's
right does not mean Israel should be
indiscriminately targeting anybody but
then the argument from the pro-israel
side is we are not just trying to Target
and and we are not trying to take out
civilians and then I can tell you this
after all the dust settles Hamas and the
left have lied about almost everything
so when someone comes says Israel's
engaged in war crimes I go hospital and
they go yeah but hospital hospital was
fake they lied it didn't happen and we
were so busy tricked into arguing over
who did it we never stopped to ask
ourselves did it even happen and the
answer was it did not well from the
beginning of the conflict I've been
saying nothing but I want peace I
condemn Hamas I even went as far as
saying F Hamas on my Twitter and but I
but I think things still have to be
pointed out Israel is a formalized
government Palestine is not nobody takes
the Palestinian government serious so
when you know bombs are being dropped on
residential buildings in Gaza you have
to point that out and if you say that
Hamas is using those to protect whatever
they have there inside well you know
Israel is very capable of going in with
Insurgent teams and getting out or
killing whoever they need to the West
supplies them with a ton of money and a
ton of training with our armed forces
and so I think they're perfectly capable
of going in I don't see a need for
leveling an entire building and You' and
the problem is I don't think you'd see
the reaction that you're talking about
if you didn't have Evangelical
Christians on Twitter saying glass Gaza
you know te make it a parking lot like
this incendiary rhetoric that just has
no care for human regard because it's
more about Humanity than anything I
could care less if it's Israeli or
Palestinian it's about humanity and
people are being killed at rates you've
never seen before 2014 88 Israelis died
and
2329 Palestinians died no one was
calling it no one was calling you know
what what's going on over there in the
Middle East we should get involved I I
don't think comparing the total number
of dead answers the question of what how
or why and does not indicate
justification or I just don't like how
the media covers it differently because
the first time you have an Israeli
attack then it's like oh my gosh the
world's ending World War III but
Palestinians have been being killed for
years and you're having no coverage of
it and that's that statistic I just gave
you that's one Israeli for every 27
Palestinian doesn't mean anything well
it does to me because if for a decade 20
times more Palestinians have been killed
So when you say why why but hold on uh
who are these Palestinians they're
innocence civilians how but I like so
this is the issue I take with it I am
the United States I am not Israel or
Palestine I know that Hamas just invaded
killed a whole bunch of civilians right
Israel responded Hamas lied about a
hospital being leveled and 500 people
dying totally fabricated Hamas is wrong
and so now the premise any point you
initiate uh Israel's blunt up buildings
lie not interested did prove it I I I
took Hamas at face value boy was that a
mistake when they said it was an Israeli
air strike we we actually like wow could
it have been an airay I mean we don't we
don't even know I mean oh oh man and
then it was a Hamas rocket likely
misfired and then the payload dropped
into a parking lot killing killing
people that's John France said it was 10
to 50 people and maybe maybe it was a
parking lot we have no idea so look look
those are the report so then I hear yeah
but what about wi white phosphorus bro
I'm sorry but the people Mar through the
street who are saying from The River To
The Sea who have who lied about this
Hospital get zero benefit of the doubt
from me and that means the only word I
have is Israel's and I don't even trust
them well all I can say is we don't want
collateral damage we don't want war we
don't want civilian deaths we want peace
we want the conflict to stop the
argument then becomes should Israel air
strike or should they send in a ground
Strike Force to start executing Hamas
AOC effectively called for that yeah
saying we want precision and
intelligence so so so Israel should
invade Gaza if if they're going to
defend themselves they should not be
bombing where there's a ton of Civilian
casualties they told everyone to leave
and Hamas told everyone to but I saw
reports of people who saying my mom is
bedridden because she's sick and she
can't get up what are we supposed to do
some people have no form of getting
anywhere and they're just supposed to
see on Hebrew television that they're
supposed to get up and go somewhere I
think that's I think that's unrealistic
it's not just on television well where
else is it I mean they they put stuff
out like there's been a lot more of that
they went to the UN told the UN like get
people evacuated from this area the UN
spoke to you know representatives in
Gaza they have diplomatic channels I
just like a week ago and the UN was like
it would be very difficult to move a
million people at once I mean it's it's
an incredibly difficult situation I
think Kamas lies I think this is a lot
of violence but if we're going to return
to the premise of does America help
because like we've talked about if Joe
Biden's going to give whatever millions
of dollars to the Palestinians but we
know ultimately that'll probably end up
in the hands of Hamas but then we're
also saying Israel we're your Al like
we're not help did you hear what he said
last week what Biden said last week when
he gave that speech I think it was
on Thursday I think it was Thursday and
he said uh you know we're going to give
a bunch of Aid to Gaza and if Hamas
doesn't steal it we'll give more we did
that here and it like what are you even
talking about what do you mean like
obviously they're going to take it they
take all of it but also like he knows
that and he's still trying to play Both
Sides this is something that we're
seeing I find that more infuriating I'm
much happier to give money to our allies
and not give money to our enemies I
would rather give money to the americ in
America we already did that I don't want
do both sides of a war that we are now
easier to I like I don't like that
American and British Western Munitions
are being used to kill innocent people I
think the human loss and the toll that
that
is in any world in any world where
morality and ethics exist means we if
Israel is going to defends they send in
Insurgent teams they kill who they need
to kill whoever caused whatever attacks
took place that that's what they do they
they don't risk it they don't risk it
with announcements saying leave Gaza
leave the where are they supposed to go
to tent cities for them to bomb in glass
why any of their allies take in refugees
from because I think Gaza well King
Abdullah from Jordan said that he
doesn't want to do it because he sees it
as kind of enabling them Israel to take
over Palestine such a great reason
that's a great way to say that I thought
we learn open borders everywhere I
thought that was the answer I thought
open no just here in America only to
destroy our country okay so now you're
an
American have now said several times
when your neighborhood is like being
rided you just leave your front door
unlocked and then go defend someone
else's house that make sense I I I I'm
just genuinely curious why the why
people are so uh fervent why there's so
much fervor weird over Israel Palestine
I know I couldn't tell you as a Jew I
don't want to see my fellow Jew die and
I I I think it's sick I thought after
the Hamas attacks all the Carnage that
was left the pictures that you saw on
Twitter like I was telling you before
the show you're seeing nothing but
graphic footage all around Twitter the
Carnage that was left behind by Hamas is
Despicable and the consequence for that
should be they should be killed but it
again should be just them that are
killed Not Innocent kids I I suppose the
challenge is like Israel's choices after
being attacked are air strikes on
strategic targets which results in a lot
of collateral damage and and dead
civilians and that's horrifying or
Invasion I don't know pick one me I'm
kind of just like I don't know I'm I'm
not Israel and I'm not in this war and
the United States is is is partially I
suppose tangentially involved in this
war and I think we shouldn't be because
it's an unsolvable issue I just think if
if you've got I just Trump on this oh I
mean sure I mean but if you've got 51%
of Gaza saying they support Hamas and
even in the United States these people
are chanting from The River To The Sea
peace is not an option I mean peace is
the preferred outcome but it's not an
option when you have one side Sayang
from The River To The Sea yeah but the
majority of those Folks at least I like
to think are not going to go out and
actually plant a bomb like I think that
justifying any war on Gaza because those
folks are so you know critical against
Israel that doesn't justify killing
that's not it that's Hamas using schools
and hospitals to store weapons and to
launch rockets and then attacking
Israeli civilians because as that y
professor said settlers aren't civilians
so to the people uh to 51% of people in
Gaza let's just say 51% supporting Hamas
anyone anyone some of those people were
tourists fair game kill them all that's
what they're doing that's horrifying
you're not going to get peace in in
Israel with Israel and Palestine if if
that is the view of a million people in
the Gaza Strip right yeah and I so so
what is what is what is Israel's plan um
let me ask you what do you think would
happen if the barrier fence around Gaza
was completely removed and Israel just
said anyone in Gaza can do whatever they
want they can they can freely travel
freely travel well I mean that kind of
exists now they're able to go back and
forth for jobs no no no no no I'm saying
the barrier if what would happen if the
barrier was completely removed security
around the Gaza Strip was removed and
Israel said to all of the people you can
freely move about all of Israel what
would happen I'm sure there would
probably be conflict going both ways CU
both ways yes both ways because I've
seen uh Hamas and Palestinian you think
Israeli Israelis in like Tel Aviv will
March into Gaza with guns start killing
civilians I think violence will be
conducted either way I think that I've
seen IDF soldiers treating Palestinian
kids very badly on the streets and and
sometimes they brag about you know doing
brutal things to them I think it would
go both ways regardless of the situation
so if the fenses were removed Israelis
would go into Gaza I'm not saying just
Israelis I say I know both ways that
means so that the implied is Palestinian
civilians will go into Israeli
settlements and start killing people but
you also think Israeli civilians will go
into God start killing people I didn't
say that I just think that the conflict
would go both ways I don't think it
would be good for anyone but what does
that mean both ways I think that you
know Terror or any act of violence would
be carried out both ways by both parties
in I don't know what that means like you
think the people in the G strip would
they leave the guysa strip if the
barriers were removed and security is
removed and they say you can freely move
about I don't think a lot of them would
they just stay there I mean I'm sure
there would be some tension for sure but
I don't think a lot of them would leave
the homes you think the people in Gaza
would just stay there so it's not open
air prison well if you're saying that
Palestinians now can't go to Israel they
they can I mean and I don't think a
barrier makes much of a difference if
you can get through to it to go to your
job from 9: to5 so then then so it's not
an open air prison and the complaints of
the Palestinians are just exaggerations
well I think that the land that the land
conflict is a whole another topic I mean
what belongs to who that's just a whole
another can of worms I don't want to get
into but I don't think a barrier there
is what's stopping any specific thing I
think people are able to go free and
easy regardless so the issue I suppose
is leftists are calling it an open air
prison where people are trapped and
stripped of resources well in a way they
are and that's another War crime you
mentioned because so it's a war crime
that they're trapped in there well it's
a war crime what's happening now where
electricity water food and Aid is being
cut off but they can just leave but
that's a war crime no no no no no it's
it's not if they can just leave right
that is an area where people live
innocent people live and so when you cut
off electricity who's giving them the
electricity well Israel
so they're obligated to give free
electricity to people of Gaza well when
they oversee certain supply routes
they're able to cut off food no but
people can just leave Gaza you said
right they can but they don't want to
give up their land again they don't want
to go to a tent city in some desert and
then have the land that they had in Gaza
be taken over as well I I I'm not I'm
not sure I'm following so so Israel is
providing electricity to Gaza under what
obligation do the Israelis have to give
a resource to the people of Gaza and how
is it a war crime if they decide to stop
supplying a resource it's a war crime
because those those routes those
electricity routes those trading routes
where they get their food they get their
water go through Israel so when Israel
the Israeli government cuts it off
that's a war crime why how's that a war
crime because you're disallowing
innocent civilians from having drinking
water from having electricity but so
you're you're saying that it's actually
it's not Israel isn't producing the
electricity they're just going in
between where
Norm I know a lot of the supply routes
are not just coming from Israel I don't
think there's a lot of Israeli yeah I
think they're coming froming right so so
Egypt is trying to get electricity to
Gaza but then Israel is stopping it uh I
think Egypt is trying to get Aid and
food and water and resources and medical
resources to people in Israel stopping
it how the electricity grid there works
I have no idea but I know isra Israeli
uh technology capability does not um
stop it being able to shut down power
grid I'm I'm I'm not sure I I I I follow
criticism of Israel in this line of
thinking so if if people can can come
and go as they please but they don't
want to live in a tent city so they
would choose to live somewhere with no
electricity it's a war crime well no but
you got to look at it like let's let's
make it out like it's here if you
know you know I live in Georgia if
Alabama decided
to you know attack Georgia and come in
here and say well you you gotta you got
to leave or you're not going to have
food or water or
resources I don't want my land to be
taken over so I'm going to fight against
those people in order to prevent my land
from being taken over in order to get
resources once again if your land's
already been taken historically yeah but
why has why have the Palestinians
rejected a two-state solution going back
into the 70s and even previously yeah
again I don't when it when it comes to
the land conflict I think that they
don't really see they don't really see
Israel having any claim over the land
right they they don't want Israel to
exist right that's not okay however that
doesn't justify a war crime to cut off
but what are they so what should what
should Israel what should Israel do when
they're when they have neighbors not
just not just in Gaza and the West Bank
not just the Palestinians that don't
think they have a right to exist but
they had a long-standing conflict with
Egypt they've had long-standing enemies
in Lebanon they have an their they're
the only nation in the entire region
right and they have enemies surrounding
them so when you had Trump's
Administration come in with the Abraham
Accords creating the bilateral
agreements that was starting to be
effective we recently had Saudi Arabia
and Israel almost normalizing relations
you if Israel can't even play soccer in
the Middle East League they have to play
in Europe because otherwise they would
get killed right by and Hamas Hamas
engaged in the attack they did to stop
the Abraham Accord yes negotiations and
to stop Saudi Arabia and Israel from
getting close because the Abraham
Accords essentially left the
Palestinians out of it why were the
Palestinians left out of it because they
have refused to come to a negotiating
table at any point with a consideration
of a two-state solution so we've had
Bill Clinton proposed a two-state
solution he had this idea that actually
gave Palestinians a whole bunch of stuff
that they wanted and who was it then it
was Yasir Arafat and Arafat was like nah
we're not going to do that uh you had
Obama had a two-state solution and so
finally Trump just ignored them and they
don't like that either and that's when
they lashed out and killed 1,400 people
including a whole bunch of civilians
children and so now you're saying that
there should be a ceasefire because
Israel shouldn't be fighting against the
people who are actively seeking their
extermination the problem is there are
Jews in Israeli Israeli Jews who believe
that Palestine shouldn't exist and that
they should have more of a land claim so
to make this
thing ideologically based think is
theout to people are King each innoc
people are so every should want to
ceasefire we can come to the table as
countries diplomatically after but like
you said the biggest issue right now is
to focus on the civilians that are dying
to the before we uh we came up here the
crew downstairs was watching a show
called Golden Balls that was great that
was great what Golden Balls you missed
it Han you miss was
well we were watching on the big screen
we were watching Golden Balls on the big
screen Golden Balls is a is a British
game show that fills me with righteous
IND IGN indignation and fury but is it
race based because it's British so
everybody gets uh some Golden Balls and
then in like the first round they're
like you show two of them and they have
dollar values and the goal is to build
up a big jackpot and then two of them
you don't see and you have to lie about
what they're worth you claim that oh if
you if you if if you pick me I have
10,000 and whatever in the end the way
the game works the reason why I bring it
up you there are four there are two
balls in front of each person two people
left and one of them is steal the prize
money and one of them is split the prize
money if both players agree to split the
prize money they split the prize money
if one player splits the prize money but
the other steals it the person who
steals it gets it all if both players
try to steal it they get nothing right
so you see two people look each other in
the eyes and say we're going to split
the money we're going to split it I I
will take half the jackpot that's fine
with me and they go yes and then the
game game show host says choose your
ball steal the money or split the money
and then they shake hands and they're
like we're going to split it yep and
then they both open steel they lied the
whole time it's particularly brutal when
one person says I'm going to split the
money with you and then it gets stolen
from them and they I knew it and you
know what you learn from that people
evil exists yes it does and then the
people who choose to steal the money
from the other person go yes yeah and so
here's what I see I see these leftists
marching through the street they lie
every every time every time the Hamas
Hospital thing really pissed me off yeah
and then they go uh uh they they rip
through the fences Massacre civilians
watch the videos yeah and then they go
please help us please they're shooting
us and I'm just like y'all y'all started
a fight in your losing and now I'm
supposed to be mad at the person who's
who's winning if if a guy breaks into my
house with a baton and I've got a
Remington 12 gauge people are going to
be like don't leave him alone you have a
shotgun dude broke into my house with a
weapon Israel gets attacked and they go
but 75 years ago 75 years ago nothing I
got no idea what you're talking about
okay how about we stop fighting right
now if the argument is civilian should
stop dying then Hamas is the problem and
the if the argument is we should have
peace between between Palestine and
Israel well the problem that is that
Hamas exists and so long as there is
someone who's going to steal the money
from the other person and lie about it
there's not going to be a peace
agreement any other argument is
pointless the people who are like Israel
is engaged in war crimes blah blah blah
I'm like dude there's a war going on and
and and one side is lying about
everything and started the fight and is
actively trying to Massacre civilians
arguing that every civilian is a
colonizer and from The River To The Sea
they're going to reclaim this land I'm
sorry dude peace agreements sound like a
psychotic proposal there's a man
standing before you at the front of your
house saying if you let me in your house
I will do unspeakable things to your
children and then people are like just
let them in just just let them in
negotiate you're kicking him outside
he's got no electricity outside you've
cut him off from warmth and heating in
Air Condition it's a war crime and I'm
like he's going to come in here he's
going to kill everybody no no you're
you're you're committing a war crime by
not giving him stuff and I'm just like
dude I can't I can't do this what if
hear me out we had the leaders of Hamas
Palestine and Israel get together go on
Golden Balls and see if this settles the
conflict maybe there is a way to just
get out of this using British isn't out
of the question when Trump was in office
get out of it using British
entertainment I really think it's an
underrated geopolitical diplomatic
resource cannot argue for peace after
Hamas massacres a bunch of CI civilians
starting the conflict and still right
now despite everything going on keeps
telling everyone they will kill Israelis
no matter what let let me let let's jump
to this story okay we got this the post
millennial Minneapolis city council
candidate joins crowd in chasing elderly
man after blocking Highway with
anti-israel Israel mob I saw this tweet
Andy no posted it this is crazy it is
crazy this video uh let me see post some
of it you have this massive crowd
blockading an
intersection these people in these cars
they got no idea what's going on they
surround the vehicles they begin
attacking the innocent elderly man who
has no idea what's going on the elderly
man inches forward and eventually is
able to drive through and they chase him
down after that and continue attacking
his vehicle
dude the people who are chanting free
Palestine they're doing so many things
they're in New York chanting what do we
want we want it all mhm they said we
want it all they said we want it all
that was right on the corner of that
like those videos that's where I used to
live that corner they're saying remove
the colonizers yes despite the fact that
these people who are claiming to be
Palestinian are on what they consider
stolen Native American land they are
lying about everything I was tweeting
about that cuz my ancestors were in
Brooklyn for over a 100 years and I'm
like are you serious I just think it's
dangerous to make this a one-sided issue
because there was a report I think
yesterday um a pro-israel protester was
just arrested in Shoki Illinois after
Chasing protesters and pulling out his
firearm and firing shots toward the
crowd at a pro Palestine rally so to
make this situation and demonize one
side even though like I said at the
beginning of the show Hamas is I condemn
them I hate Hamas I hate terrorists but
to make this a one-sided issue in our
country domestically it's not because
clearly we have this story here what
what it was it was a guy who did a bad
thing the problem is this is not just
limited to just one guy this is an
ideology that many people have many
people are just fundamentally against
Palestinians and Palestinians are
against you know their oppressors
whatever they deem oppressing and so it
just cannot be limited to one issue
Israel Is Not Innocent in all of this
either there are corrupt powers that be
in Israel and those people I think
instigate conflict I think they
provocate and I'm not saying this is on
is israeli's hands or anything like that
but I'm saying that Israel's Not
Innocent in all of this I that's coming
from a Jew I don't think Israel is
innocent I just think that Hamas didn't
have to choose to go in there and kill a
bunch of people well Israel didn't have
to choose to kill thousands and
thousands of Palestinians over the
course of the last decade too 20 times
more than than Israelis but they they
did what what why I don't know I
couldn't tell you well there you goah
it's a more though 20 times more like
what's the actual number 20 times more
what one number if it's one person
that's 20 people what's the number uh so
here here's here's the issue that's all
that's nebulous and immaterial to where
I am and what I'm what I'm talking about
and I and mean anything if you said in
2014 during protective Edge Hamas did X
and and Israel did y we could have that
conversation but once again when it
comes to protective Edge it is it is
Hamas attacks Israel because they
believe they they they own it all it's
all theirs they want it all and whatever
whatever reason it overlaps with the
American left we even saw what was the
current leader of Hamas saying that he's
like George Floyd yes and and they the
racist yeah that was from a couple years
ago but yeah that's a couple years ago
yeah and they've been planning this
attack for two years here's the way I
see it imagine there's a uh you're in a
mall and you hear gunshots going off mhm
you run into into an area and there are
two guys with guns and they're both
pointing that at at each other we want
them to stop however one guy started
shooting the other guy was trying to
stop the
shooter what do you do so what's
happening is there are a lot of people
who are ignorant to what's going on who
will start tell me what happened and
then the one guy says you know three
years ago this guy and the other guy
goes five years ago this guy well six
years ago this guy who started shooting
right now in the mall him and who are
you I'm trying to stop him okay what
happens if you stop the wrong guy the
crazy guy starts shooting again and
kills a bunch more civilians it is a
challenge to figure out who is right and
wrong in circumstances like this but the
idea now that Hamas attacks Israel and
therefore like we're going to have this
historical debate is is is pointless to
me we can have a debate about American
financing for foreign governments and
all that stuff and I'm just like this is
a really good reason we shouldn't be
involved in forign Conflict agreed
because this is what you get the problem
is it's bleeding out all across the
world and for some reason it escapes me
people are so
ideologically just impassioned by Israel
it is the craziest thing in the world I
despise it more than anything the the
this fervor this zealotry don't care if
you're for or against Israel if you've
got a rational argument in favor of
Israel defending itself totally hear you
if you got a rational argument about
1947 19 was it 1967 or 68 or whatever
which one there was uh 67 and that Six
Day War and then in 73 was the Y War I I
have almost never had I would say 2% of
the conversations that have ever risen
about Israel have been like historically
accurate calm conversations
it there there is always some like look
dude I'll be like you're saying like
Israel's committing war crimes and doing
all stuff and I'm just like that doesn't
mean anything it's it's completely
meaningless Hamas committed war crimes
oh Hamas committed war crimes how could
you be mad at Israel like it just mud
being thrown back and forth yeah but the
problem is Israel's a formalized
government and palestine's not and why
is that a problem because Israel is an
ally and when those are American
Munitions being thrown over the borders
and onto pal Ian innocent people that
that implicates Us in some of that guilt
it's collateral damage it's I I don't
look at innocent children dying and call
that collateral damage that's the
definition collateral collateral damage
is in military operation when civilians
die but I don't just shrug it off is
what I'm saying we're not trying to
shrug it off I'm saying that there needs
to be there needs to be peace like she
said we should have everybody from every
party come to the table and that I think
that was gonna happen um and it end up
it but I just feel that that's like
that's like it's it's so naive to look
at what just happened and think the
answer is as simple as a ceasefire or
peace it's just never going to happen
the answer is obviously British
Entertainment Television I'll say it
once I'll say it again well like you
said America should not be involved
that's what we have to say first we have
to put America First and America
shouldn't be in the Middle East and
America shouldn't be in uh Europe uh we
shouldn't be fighting anyone's War for
them and we should be worrying about the
problems here like again I say our young
men are killing themselves at rates
we've never seen before veterans and we
have our politicians who are
prioritizing every other issue above the
moon but these these people that are
killing themselves here at home and I
think peace is definitely achievable
because when Donald Trump was in office
there was World Peace there was no war
going on I think people saw a weak point
in Biden's presidency and they said well
we're going to strike and we're going to
create a conflict and we're going to
instigate World War II I mean even this
video of Biden sort of muttering into
the microphone I have to go to The
Situation Room this is not the the
representation of our country I would
like uh and I think it is apparent to
everyone that there are a lot of forces
in the world that are now testing the
strength of American leadership which I
hate to say it as much as I love America
the Joe Biden Administration is not
presenting a strong front to to the
Nations or to to the International
Community um so I you know we saw
Ukraine happen we're seeing things
happen in the Middle East I will not be
surprised uh I personally feel like
we're counting down until an invasion of
Taiwan it seems like just uh explosions
happening all over the place and the
question is at what point do we say we
have to put our own domestic priorities
before everything else even when we have
historic ties or relationships
diplomatically I do agree with you Tim
about what you said about we shouldn't
be focusing on the sins of the father
and the grandparent that shouldn't be
the topic of today so I do agree with
you on that we should be Focus yeah I
agree I think the challenge for me is
like when you learn about how evil
really exists and I
wonder when it happens for the average
person and I wonder if so many people in
the United States especially like these
people surrounding these vehicles many
of these
leftists I I perhaps they can't see the
forest for the trees perhaps you know
they are the horde of evil and because
they can't see it or they're not victims
of it they can't understand the people
here that like so this video of these
these people in the mob right they're
evil people yeah but this is the
banality of evil this is not malicious
these people aren't individually
deciding to take actions but they're
part of a horde which is victimizing
innocent people sure agreed they've not
experienced the brunt force on the other
side of this so they don't truly get it
yep I wonder if there's a point in
people's lives where they experience
evil and then and then start to realize
CU for me when I'm younger I'm like oh
good and evil are subjective everyone
thinks they're they're they're doing the
right thing and then I got older and
actually had some experience I'm like oh
wow evil people certainly exist oh yeah
pure evil no question I mean this is a
lot of them not to like jump stories but
when you this uh off-duty pilot who
theoretically tried to turn off the
engine of a plane in air today I mean
they're still investigating what
happened there but is this what did
happen there okay so we're going to
we're going to get to this in a little
bit I mean I don't want to jump stories
oh sorry I want jump stories but I'm
just saying like when you are trying to
unpack something that's happened and
when you when you see uh any kind of
incident from the outside you have to
ask yourself is this person evil did
they just want to see the world born or
you know a lot of time we hear it now
where it's like oh there's a mental
health issue maybe they're having
psychotic break who knows we don't know
what plays into someone else's
motivations on the other hand the
consequences of their actions remain the
same no matter what their motivation was
Hamas is evil Israel is a spattering mix
of government institutions corrupt
wealthy individ individuals good
civilians who are trying to live
peacefully Palace a Gaza specifically is
seems to be 50/50 between Hamas and
people who want to be left alone which
creates a very pressing challenge yeah
the issue I see here is you can't
negotiate with evil no no no I mean like
you can try to negotiate with evil you
can desperately beg evil for peace and
then they'll agree with you and then
turn around and put the knife in your
back right like those people on Golden
Balls no no no joke that's why I brought
it up it's a it's a silly show but I'm
watching this and I'm just
like evil people will stare you in the
eye and they will try to steal
everything from you and they will cheer
for themselves as they destroy you and I
think this is one of the issues that
without acknowledging if you can't ack
that some people just are evil then you
can't acknowledge that there are people
who will not no matter how hard you want
them to understand relate to or try to
live by a moral code that you or your
community share right an evil person has
no uh reason to feel bad about anything
because their motivations are completely
contrary to yours if you're a good
person and I think that's really hard to
uh wrap your head around like can can
evil forces exist in the world and can
you potentially change them and I just
don't think that's true and this is I'm
not trying to comment you politically
now I'm now I'm just talking talking
philosophically evil exists no matter
what how what you do to contain it and
if someone can be converted from Evil is
a really serious question well that's
why we have histories of moral
philosophy but people I think on average
I'm willing to bet most people don't
experience abject evil and I think the
more you you're exposed to various
ideologies various the more people you
meet it increases the likelihood you
meet people who are truly evil there's a
lot of them
but I don't think it's the majority of
humans but there's a lot of them I have
experienced things that I would just say
like you know somewhat private personal
stuff I did not believe such evil could
exist and I just don't understand how
people could be so evil but oh you
better believe it we were swatted 15
times in the span of a year and we have
very very high confidence we know who it
was the police won't do anything about
it they don't care about you multiple
law enforcement agencies won't do
anything about it we've reported we've
given them evidence they don't care the
people who did it who we assume we know
did it and the people who are aiding
those who did it we don't know 100% who
did we do know who is aiding them who is
providing them with Intel and allowing
them to do it and I just could not
believe that people I've known and
trusted for decades would for no reason
literally none smile on their face every
day and then one and then and then
behind the scenes laugh and smirk as
they tried to burn everything down and
kill people it's shocking when that
happens when you trust someone and then
they just turn on you they try and
destroy your life but just just just to
ask people to understand this imagine
someone you've known literally your
whole life mhm they've they've been to
your house for dinner dozens hundreds of
times you've gone to theme parks and V
you vacationed with them and their
family and then one day you find out
they were pouring Drano in your cereal
trying to kill you you just be like I
but why it's hard to get over something
and and they're laughing when they when
you find out laughing saying I almost
got it oh man and you're like evil
people exist do you know that story
about one of the most infamous female
poisoners uh I I'll look up her name in
a second but she was based in Alabama I
believe and uh she just poisoned she had
five daughters poisoned them all
poisoned her husband poisoned the next
guy she only got caught because she
married this like young guy and he was
at a VA hospital and when she would
leave for a while for like a couple
weeks he would get better and then she
would be there and he would get worse
and it got caught and when they asked
her like why why would you do this
especially to your own children to your
mother like it was it was a crazy amount
this this went on for like I think
several decades uh she just said I don't
know there's something wrong with me I
don't know why I did it she had no
explanation for her actions that she did
several different ways over the course
of several decades that's crazy how do
you justify that how do you explain
something like that when you when you
look at like you know we're showing this
video of this left this leftist
attacking this vehicle the these people
are cheering and dancing as they attack
innocent people we saw this with the
George Floyd riots it is Mindless yeah
evil how do you negotiate for peace with
people who are laughing at causing
suffering you you have to show them
Christ that's the only way I mean any
anyone who thinks they're going to find
a peaceful lifestyle and have a great
eternity after and not have Christ at
the center of their their life here on
Earth are just stupid and I think you're
going to see evil play out all over the
world until people realize that and put
Christ first um but I will tell you
again this this whole conflict goes back
to putting America first we need to stay
out of it we don't need to get involved
in another yearslong War evil exists
I'll tell you one thing being a young
guy on the political scene I lived in DC
for 4 years or 4 months sorry and I can
tell you I've never seen evil like I
have in DC oh man coming across folks
it's the hell mouth yeah coming across
older men uh saying things to me um and
blackmail attempting to Blackmail and
extort me for things that they wanted in
exchange I'm telling you Unthinkable
things and I you know the I couldn't
think anyone else for my protection
other than Christ if if it wasn't for
him and me to be able to pray and rely
on him I wouldn't have made it through
living there for only four months so I
can't imagine the folks that are
entrenched in that mess every day DC
concentrates a lot of evil and um one
meersburg personality type it's like I
TJ it's whatever Hillary Clinton is
there's there's a huge proportion of
them in DC over represented and also
that personality type doesn't like to
share space with the same personality
type so sorry DC you're meant to split
apart
man yeah I don't know I feel bad for
like there's like the dude and his wife
on a farm and they're just like they got
a handful of cows and pigs and sheeps
and goats and they're like we got enough
for our family and our friends just
leave us alone and then you've got
people who are just laughing and smiling
hoping to burn it down for no reason
well included in those people trying to
laugh and burn it down for no reason is
the Biden Administration you remember
the agriculture secretary intentionally
uh started giving out loans specifically
to minority groups like farmer minority
farmers who were from a minority group
and um the it turned out that that was
illegal so some Farmers took him to
court over that and the judge was like
you can't fix previous racism with new
racism that's not how it works that's
not effective and so they knocked that
thing out but then Biden was mad about
it and I was like oh if you based on
your skin color you should get more
money first uh it was total trash I do
think Joe Biden is racist you're right
Libby I think I think Joe Biden is
racist as well I think he's yeah want
his kids to go to those jungle schools
whereever Corp with corn poop his hair
is shine in the that so disgusting
that's the most disgusting thing I
hadn't seen the whole thing about that
until recently and I was like he was
talking about children stroking his leg
hair and watch pervert what kind of
horrible pervert that is the the female
poisoners referencing before was ronabel
Martin I believe um but anyways
interesting she's a lots of lots of
people down and uh only I think her
fourth husband survived we're going to
jump to this story from msn.com rehosted
from Daily Express vlir Putin suffers
Cardiac Arrest sparking massive alarm in
Kremlin inner circle and a shout out to
Timothy Whitaker in the Super Chat who
asked I had not seen this story it's
from 16 hours ago totally missed this
one but uh I did just check it real
quick and there are a ton of outlets
that are covering this saying Vladimir
Putin is alleged to have suffered a
cardiac arrest arrest in his private
Moscow apartment on Sunday evening a
telegram Channel believed to be run by a
former Kremlin Insider reported that
incident saying the Russian leader was
found by guards on the floor of the
bedroom lying on the floor rolling his
eyes oh doctors were reportedly called
in immediately and they later diagnosed
a 71-year-old having suffered a cardiac
arrest it's different from a heart
attack cardia arrest is when heart stops
something like this was reported about
Putin a couple months ago wasn't it he's
been having a lot of medical issues
that's horrible to hear well I mean the
scary thing is what happens to Russia
without Putin yeah it's a big vacuum
yeah yep he not a good dude dude well
you know what they might just start
fighting among themselves and then lose
all uh lose all interest in Ukraine and
then we could just be like okay see you
see you next time this might prevent
World War I that would be helpful it's
kind of a horrifying thing to think like
if this man dies World War III is
averted well yeah then Russian Civil War
3 or four they do that a lot yeah the
thing is whoever takes over for Russia
and we we would think they might fun
amongst themselves but we don't actually
know if there's not a clear uh successor
to his throne could be even
worse they have pren out of the way
remember the so he's out of the way and
so a bunch of like cuz he would be much
tougher on Ukraine than uh but the next
guy might be too you right I agree but
didn't they get rid of most of those
guys in that how do you know I don't
know anything I don't know anything
which is why we didn't cover the story
at post millennial I just couldn't tell
yeah it's hard uh and also when you see
stuff like this it's hard for me not to
be like when is the Kremlin statement
saying like somebody slipped poon his
com but yeah I was interested in this
story too and I couldn't track down
like I find it very difficult to cover
overseas stuff because I really I really
only know just the one language well
especially with China and Russia I think
if if anything I was actually was
concerned about this as well if there's
power vacuum this is before I even knew
that he had this heart attack I talked
with a friend of mine if there is a
power vacuum in Russia what's to say
that China isn't going to go you know
knocking on Russia's door I don't know
I'm I'm just you know it's just a whole
other thing I'm throwing out there but
there's def definitely animosity between
totally random crazy thought that you
probably start thinking about when you
get older it's like you could be taking
a shower in the morning and like let's
say your wife or your husband or
whatever is like all right I'm going to
go you know walk the dog or whatever and
then you slip and hit your head and
you're dead that's why you should get
married CU they'll come back after they
walk the dog and be like the shower is
still running and they'll check on you
and that's and that's the thing like un
they hate you there a lot there are lot
of stories about like people who will
just go missing and then a week later
people are just like let's go check up
they've been missing for a week and
they're like oh they slept in the
bathroom and died yeah yeah like you
could just like Putin so the report is
like his guards heard a thump and then
ran up and found him I don't know if
they actually had a heart attack right
they're saying unconfirmed reports but a
bunch of OTS are carrying this this this
this rumor and just imagine like for the
average person who has a heart attack
there is no guard waiting downstairs to
hear the Thum that's why they invented
the button thing although if you have a
heart attack your unconscious you can't
press Your Life Alert button although
there's I think one that like if you
fall hard enough it'll toally there's
like necklaces and stuff too oh the
iPhone does that yeah there was a there
was a what is it like if you get into a
car accident it instantly calls 911 or
whatever yeah yeah you got Tey so crazy
well like there's a story where a dude
dropped the phone and the phone thought
it was a car accident so it called the
police and they found it or something oh
wow like fell off his bike or something
like that I remember it was just a
couple years ago my mom said honey I I'm
suddenly afraid of falling down that
must be a crazy she's like she's in her
mid 70s she's extremely active she just
got back from a month traveling around
Italy right Italy and Ireland and she
just living her wherever she was yeah
she just does whatever she wants but
she's still a little bit afraid of
falling
down yeah yeah I just kind of hope that
when I'm old I'm like fat and so when I
fall down it doesn't cushioning nothing
gets broken that is the argument for
obesity right now although your bones
get brittle you can't walk around you
get the veins you have a heart issue
that seems bad to the diabet you know no
the good news is if you're fat you won't
get old oh if you're fat you won't get
old so that's a win wow that's how you
young forever the takes you first
I'll just stop working out all
together I'm also equally concerned that
Putin having a heart attack could lead
to World War II yeah that's what what's
the alternate scenario what do you think
that without Putin stabilizing the
region it results in power struggles and
then it leads to conflict outside of
outside of Russia which drags other
people in Putin may be a stabilizing
Force stopping certain elements of of
the Russian military from engaging in
certain actions right yeah like look at
Gaddafi after after he went to Libya
collapsed yeah but I mean worse than
that let's say like putad heart attack
and dies then a military leader says I'm
the next in command so I'm going to do
this thing fighting erupts inside Russia
but then this guy says send in new you
know K or whatever something crazy yeah
yeah Putin's been a tough Force for for
Russia for a long time and I I don't
think that this uh war is just simple
land dispute I think it's definitely a
proxy war to test the endurance of
Russia um you know kind of caused by
American influence but yeah I don't want
I I would rather Putin not die I think
he's he's protected a lot of the
Christian Community in in Russia and
you've seen zalinsky shut down Orthodox
churches in Ukraine and I'm not saying
they were Russian Orthodox right the
Russian Orthodox Churches yeah
interesting yeah and so I don't know I
do think it would bring in uh World War
II if he died yeah I mean I mean the
question at this point is there are so
many different scenarios to get us into
World War III are there any scenarios to
keep us out to keep it from happening
put America First stay away everyone
else but that would still multiple
arguments have been made for why that
would result in World War the first two
other world wars started when America
stay out so I be anything Ben Chapo's
argument is that if Iran or other
countries stage a ground invasion of of
Israel or begin air strikes Israel will
respond with nuclear weapons which will
create regional conflict which bleeds
out into h feere whatever International
yeah and then the US has no choice but
to get involved well Mark Levan was on
Fox News the other day and he was just
going like eviscerating the host saying
well Israel is surrounded and they may
have to resort to uh you know nuclear
weapons just infuriated and I I don't
think it'll come to that point I don't
think it'll come to that point unless
Israel provokes it I just don't see that
happening but what I will say is even if
it does you know bleed out into the
International Community
I still think America should stay out of
it I think we're a strong enough entity
to keep to ourselves what about NATO do
you don't think we should I think we
should pull out NATO you don't think we
should defend our allies I think we
should pull out of NATO so we should be
have no friends at all in the world I
think our friends should be ourselves
and we should put America first because
we haven't done that in we're be like
that we're going to be like that girl in
New York who marries
herself stages a whole isolation she's
so happy oh my God she is so happy she
has no children she has no man she has a
very nice dress and is happy girl
probably locks her apartment door which
is the thing I think America should do I
think we should completely talk about
the Border when she falls down in the
shower there is nobody there to help her
I mean we have a bunch of states that
are the size of European countries I I
can't say what our our interventionist
strategy should be I generally feel like
before we delve in further to any
International Skirmish we should have a
stronger border policy uh and then we
can talk about it it's hard to have
these ation knowing that we are like
yeah yeah yeah you're bad and we want to
support you and also come across our
border anytime no questions asked also
maybe from Canada if you fly there and
hop like this is not good we need a
strong National Defense Trump says it
this is coming straight from Trump's
mouth we have to put America first
that's not a controversial thing to say
we've got so many problems that are
crippling us and leaving us basically
paralyzed in the water and our kids are
killing themselves because they have no
purpose their gender dysphoric and we're
focusing on a bunch of regional
skirmishes thousands of miles halfway
around the world let's focus on putting
America First why is that so I agree but
being being isolationism being
isolationist and saying we're going to
totally isolate ourselves is also kind
of a death now because we don't have
enough manufacturing to keep this
country going we have so many things
that are also need to buil up our
resources not are not in the same level
as other countries we have we have
natural gas and we have oil we should be
drilling I with that I'm sure you agree
with that as well but I still think that
like okay if you want to do that we'll
give ourselves like a 20 timeline
because we can't just do that tomorrow
or we're screwed yeah well I think like
you said uh we should be an autonomous
country but maybe we should build the
time machine and go back and put the
factories back in America I mean there's
a lot of stuff we should have done we've
been on a bad path for a long time I
don't think that we should give up and
say like well we've already been engaged
we don't have these things like but I
acknowledge I think you're totally right
we aren't necessarily in a position to
say well we're just going to do
absolutely
nothing before everything else we need
to think about especially if it's an
international war and we know that the
Biden Administration is leaked the thing
is Americans are not used to conflict
being fought on American soil so I think
it's really important that we secure the
border right it was like it's been 7
million people since the Biden
Administration took office and in Trump
in 2020 it was less than half a million
yes and the majority of them are
fighting it was 480,000 four no 4 yeah
480,000 in 2020 I'm pretty sure and it's
been 7 million since 2021 so good I'm
glad that we're entering International
skirmishes this is a great idea well
they're trying to displace the nation's
image bearers and I think that's you've
seen that just the way that they
demonize white people white Christians
especially white Christian men moreover
especially they're trying to do that and
they're like you said they're sing 7
million people and that's a huge
fraction of our population and I don't
think we should stand oddly by we need a
and they're not done they're flying
people in from Venezuela they're like oh
these Venezuelans they should get all of
the things and New Yorkers should get
nothing we'll just send everybody we got
to reinforce our we got to have a
stronger National Defense otherwise
we're going to be the laughing stock in
the next 10 years I agree but I think 10
years I know right already there pretty
much it's like right now yeah billions
it's why I am so interested to see an
argument from the Democrats to keep Joe
Biden in office right if we are on the
brink of all these things and we have so
many issues domestically and then we
have our slurring President Joe B do you
call it with the dementia Shuffle yeah
the dementia Shuffle is a real term I
mean this is this is not the guy that I
want at the Forefront and I actually
think Democrats they didn't like him
before how could you be like yes I feel
confident and safe when looking at
President Joe Biden there's no way
there's a there's a video going around
of a guy presumably in the Army wearing
his like uniform and he's singing some
song and then it flashes and he's a drag
queen oh God and it's like there's more
than one of this but I'm like that
should be immediate dishonorable
discharge yeah I agree I think so too
I've seen that video I don't like it
there's like there's a couple of them
but there's one right now and the reason
I say this or I would even I would even
accept administrative discharge because
it's the the our enemies look at our
they look at our culture our country to
determine whether or not they think we
are strong or weak and if we appear weak
we will be attacked even if we are
strong oh yeah there's not much weaker
than a fella in a dress they let a
master Sant wear bondage gear in his
army photo I saw that a puy it's not
about any it's it's it is about looking
looking weak internationally and putting
putting our other men women at at risk
the message we should be giving off is
that like that Russian military
commercial where the guy like shaved
head jumps out of a plane lands in the
ice he's got a gun we want to terrify
that's why people wear skull masks they
want to be terrifying and invoke death
right because then you minimize the the
the the likelihood of conflict the more
you intimidate and people but if if if
if what we are seeing in our in our
culture in the Army in the armed forces
is a bunch of AFF feminite men twerking
and trying to be you know like women
then our enemies are going to be like if
there ever was a time to destroy America
it's now yeah yeah if there's ever a
time to compare America to the great
Satan it's right now just just weakness
yeah you can call whatever you want
otherwise morality is not the question
the question is is this guy a you know
you remember the mountain from uh uh
Game of Thrones yeah is it the mountain
he just had a second baby just everyone
knows this guy how tall was he like 6
seven 100 like 68 like 30 71 I don't
know I'll look it up but how much did he
weigh like 300 and something pounds of
muscle it's crazy that of scary it all
stems from our nation's breakdown and
really alienation from Christ and
Christianity because that's what our
nation was supposed to be have been
rooted in and you had bunch of people
come in and tear everything down and
it's unfortunately eroded into our
military I ch
I'm yeah know I agree with you 100%
pacifists Christian uh who who was say
who was saying this it was uh Patrick
David he's 6 foot n he's 400 PB
400 oh which seems crazy he did just
have a second baby that's why he's on uh
Patrick B David brought this up it's the
tolerant Christians who kept allowing
these evil people to keep doing more and
more and more and just sat back and let
it happen yeah I agree it's like the the
whole like the the adage of like the
Republicans being the the breaks on the
Democrat Party which is just the truth
it's just Christian liberalism a lying
people to do what they want and saying
oh well turn to the cheek turn to the
cheek turn to the check if you do that
too much eventually you know I love that
you know Sheamus I think Sheamus has
mentioned it where it's like the left
will say but as a Christian you should
be doing this and then his response is
as someone who hates Christians I'm not
going to take your word on Christianity
yeah yeah true yeah it's horrible
they're they're trying to kill you guys
like I my dad's Colombia my dad
immigrated here illegally um and they're
trying to kill you guys you guys built
the best Empire in history and it's a
nation that th D and did so well and was
feared on the world stage and now it's
become this laughing stock that gives
billions out to anyone who provokes
their neighbor into a war and they're
trying to kill you guys for being white
Christian men it's unreal and we've got
to reinforce God back in our society
back in our schools we cannot have our
textbooks permeated by any type of
propaganda that's foreign we need Christ
back in the schools and I'm saying that
as a Messianic Jew American
values yeah founding
fathers IND a lot of our day-to-day
culture doesn't reinforce American
values generally like we we can talk
about the history books and we can talk
about Hollywood or whatever else but I
also think day-to-day people don't live
lives that are uh reflective of American
values there are some people who do but
I think you know being openly patriotic
being there for Community you know doing
things to serve those around you
protecting your family there are some
enclaves of of American culture that
live that way but a lot of uh
predominant centers of American
populations don't have that at the core
and that's sad I I don't want to call
out this company so I'm asking you know
everybody who's here just not to name
the company but we recently bought a
bunch of products from one company just
as like you know on a whim and this
company which produces a variety of
meats and meat
snacks writes their their mission of
inclusivity and a diverse healthy snack
and I'm just like what about dried meat
is diverse and inclusive this is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard it's
very and so I I don't want to I don't
want to again directly name the company
cuz I'll let them do their thing we
won't buy from them ever again you know
whatever no beef it's just it's become a
it's a cult yeah where it's like we're
we're making a series of neck ties but
our neck ties are inclusive how anybody
can wear them
yeah well I didn't I didn't know that
before I didn't know that literally
anyone could buy this tie and put it on
thank you for saying it directly I've
actually been thinking recently I need a
neck tie oh there you go our NE our
inclusive NEC better buy the inclusive
one so that I'm not called they're
diverse as well yeah I need a diverse
right
because white people black people
Mexican people and agents they can all
wear them are you sure I'm worried about
that we actually tested them to make
sure can women also wear these NE ties
okay I need a I need a scientific study
and a written certification from the
company because I just can't take your
word for it both of you are bigoted
let's make sure they put it on the
package these companies should are
writing like our comp you know our
product is to to ensure a diverse and
inclusive meat snack and it's like huh
that also sounds creepy that starts to
sound like right on the edge of
cannibalism really like it what kind of
meat are I really want to only know a
specific I don't want diverse I want
specifically one type of meat I want you
to label it on the package how did that
type of thinking introduced itself into
our country where did it come from who
introduced it well I think you don't
know this the history of beef jerky is
that only racist white men and so we
need to find a way to make it accessible
to Urban liberals right well the uh the
left are uh you know default liberals is
what Breitbart called them uh I believe
that's what he called them because they
don't actually
have they don't seek out information
they just hear it and they adhere to it
so I want to do a game show and um we
should we should totally do this not
even kidding and it's political trivia
but the contestants are going to be like
two people from the left and two people
from the right two self-identified
liberals two self-identified
conservatives and then we ask questions
that'd be cool you know I'm not saying I
know exactly how it would turn out and
who would tend to be right or whatever
you know but I think the right would
tend to have because the the the right
argues all the time about various
political issues
what is described as the right in the
culture War includes Libertarians who
are going to start quoting a whole bunch
of like Anarchist philosophers like real
ones not the left weirdos and people on
the left are going to be like huh yeah
you you get someone who's like a liberal
activist and you put them up up against
a conservative activist and you ask
about modern politics what was the name
of the the the uh uh the private
military contractor who died in a plane
crash who was deeply involved in the
Ukraine war
prion and what's gonna happen is a
conservative is going to say that right
away like well yeah and the Liberals
goingon to be like I don't know what
you're talking about right what is the
name of the prosecutor fired in Ukraine
after Joe Biden flew to the country and
threatened to withhold $1 billion oh I
know the name Victor Shen oh wow look at
that I'm willing to bet you bring a you
have a liberal and a conservative
commentator and they're the Liberals
going to be like what what are you what
even talking about they're making Tik
toks well it's the new the new liberals
would not get any of this stuff my
grandma was a liberal and she would have
she paid attention to everything and
then you'd say like what you know uh if
we get uh specific on well-regulated
referred to a type of armed individual
that went by this
name militia regulars oh regulars it's
in the name I think this is a great game
show I think we should start I play also
hijacked pop culture crisis today and
said that we should start a game show
where we find Brett a wife and turn it
into the dating game I so we're just the
whole company we're just turning into we
the new Game Show Network I got one for
you it I I got one I think maybe uh I'm
not so sure anyone would be able to
answer okay on his famous ride Paul
Rivier historically declared what the
regular British are coming the regulars
are coming men are real men why would
Paul River say The British are coming
when and they were all British yeah
right and the country was split between
Loyalists and uh uh uh Patriots wonder
why they changed that in the textbooks
or why that's what everyone it was just
a poem it wasn't the British are coming
it's like it's like the cops showing up
the Americans are here it's like just
cops yeah hey the regulars are coming
which were were effectively like the law
enforcement of the day so poem made it
propaganda it was Longfellow it I I
don't know that that is the lead
propagandist in American culture I'm
just kidding it is it is commonly
believed he said the British are coming
but my readings of Academia and Serge
got this tooo yeah that he said the
regulars are coming it's a it's a it's
apocryphal that he said is it apocryphal
the right word I think so I think so
yeah yeah well it was it was you know
art it's also like for Americans like
200 years later they just like well you
just me to British so like we'll just
bread it in I'm sure there so many cool
stories in the American Revolution it's
crazy those people were Crusaders those
were Crusaders those were young men who
were actually impassioned on being
Patriots for the country and many of
them believed in Christ and many of them
were willing to lay down their lives for
the values they oh dude doing a like a
religion trivia one with like a liberal
and a conservative oh wait wait as Ian
host then I'm with it whenever I go up
to uh whenever I go up to Boston which
I'm going to be doing again for
Thanksgiving because that's a tradition
it's our tradition me and my brother and
my son and this year my brother's
girlfriend it's coming we go out for
dinner for Thanksgiving uh this is our
third year of this tradition and we have
the best time but anyway the way up I
always stop at Lexington and Conquer for
the shot hurt around the world and to
see where Nathaniel Hawthorne lived in
the old mans and I love it I love I mean
I love Hawthorne but I love Lexington
conquered I love like just being there
in this space and it's such a small area
it's a little bridge this was my
favorite thing about growing up in New
England which is that when you study
American revolutionary history which you
do for every year until they have to
make you study other things you get the
best field trips because everything is
within driving disc
here
andne it I mean feel for the of you know
Texas teaches his own history but uh it
was it was one of the best parts of
where I grew up because the American
Revolutionary War is such a present and
real part of that that region of the
country well did you have this like cuz
uh because I grew up in the South Shore
of Boston and most of the history we
learned was revolutionary war history
and then when I moved to Philadelphia
like all the history was about you know
After the Revolution and it was about
the like the creating of the
Constitution I feel like American
Regional history is such a cool thing
yeah we don't appreciate American
regionalism enough I mean this is the
thing that I think we lose again not
that you should not be informed of
what's going on in the world but I I
love that Texas teaches own history I
know you know some students in West
Virginia do some courses in West
Virginia history there are all kinds of
regional influences like even if you
talk about um and West Virginia has so
much Civil War history right if you talk
about like how Minneapolis St Paul came
to be a lot of that is because of the
Scandinavian uh immigration that
happened there America America has such
an interesting Regional history that
unfortunately I feel like local
governments local school systems do not
put enough of an emphas emphas emphasis
on I'm so sorry uh that you're right you
know it is it is sort of a crime against
ourselves it's not going to necessarily
solve peace in the Middle East but it
would be nice to remember our heritage
and know about all of these things that
us who we are I mean the the massive
protest that we saw in Bay Ridge
Brooklyn over the weekend which is ex
like it went up Fifth Avenue Bay Ridge
Bay Ridge Brooklyn isn't that a Jewish
area uh well it's an immigrant
neighborhood and it's a very Arab
neighborhood and there's a lot of Jews
in the neighborhood and there's Jews all
around it flat Bush uh burrow park
that's where that famous bagel place is
there's a lot of good bagel places in
famous one I'm not going to I don't want
to shout them out because I don't
because you don't like them no because I
don't want someone throw brick to their
window that's fair but there's a lot of
good bagel places in the neighborhood
you can always get get a good bagel um
Bay Ridge is a this great neighborhood I
moved there years and years ago uh
and Bay Ridge has always been an
immigrant neighborhood so there were
Norwegians there there were Norwegians
there because they were building the
verizo bridge that was primarily
Norwegian there were Greeks that came in
there were Italians that came in there
were uh Chinese there's not any Indians
and you can tell because there's no good
Indian food in the neighborhood at all
um but there Central Americans Mexicans
Arabs you liveed there right I lived
there for a long time I don't live there
now I moved um but uh it was a great
neighborhood a ton of great food lots of
Jewish people lots of Arab people um
lots of Teslas it's like there's a lot
of wealth neighor part of our cultural
exploit but I found it so surprising and
I'd seen a pro Palestinian protests
there in the neighborhood before um but
it was always much smaller and this was
a huge massive protest and seeing the
police blocking off streets and one of
the streets that I saw police in videos
blocking off was a street where one of
my old friends lives and he's Israeli
and his whole family lives there and I'm
just like
imagining him and his family and their
kids like seeing this and they're Jewish
and I'm just like seeing this happen and
I was like I don't think that I don't
like that I don't like that they
feel like their neighborhood is under SE
that there's helicopters going on and
the thing about it being Bay Ridge is
that this is just this classic old
immigrant neighborhood and I feel like
if the people in that neighborhood if
the schools were better at teaching
Brooklyn history if the schools were
better at you know if the city was
better appreciating itself then those
kids would all know like oh this is not
just an Arab neighborhood this is a
classic immigrant neighborhood and when
we move on there's going to be a
different group of immigrants that's
going to move in here and it's just
that's sort of how Bay Ridge goes like
it it belongs to nobody it belongs to
everybody it's just a constant like well
it's a New York neighborhood it belongs
it's a very New York neighborhood yeah
we're going to go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button and head over to
timcast.net click join us and you will
get access to the uncensored members
only show coming up at 10 p.m. you don't
want to miss it it's going to be fun
we're going to have y'all call in and
talk to us but in the meantime let's
read your super chats we got Clint
Torres he got the first place good job
super chat with howdy people howdy howdy
Quantum strange cork says first no
second dzala says first nope third pork
chop Express says you know uh no no
sorry I don't know if I do actually Noe
fourth fourth
all right gold Deux production says hey
Tim you brought up again the new cars
can be remotely controlled in your
culture War segment again I just want to
clarify that only applies to new
vehicles with electric power steering
steering not hydraulic power steering
interesting okay thank you for the for
the
correction Alan Choice says Tim is not a
s the problem is that dating has to be a
way to find a spout find a spouse has
essentially replaced marriage in which
case you are correct so just to clarify
I did a segment earlier there's a woman
being interviewed and the guy asks her
how much should a man spend on a first
date for you and she goes $200 and he's
like why and then she explains it and I
said she's correct and then you know
everybody starts having a huge debate
over it but my position was basically
just like if you're arguing it's too
much money then your argument is this
woman has expensive tastes not that
she's wrong you're arguing well you know
I couldn't afford that so I think a lot
of the shock comes from I couldn't
afford $200 to going to date with a
woman but This Woman's in like Miami and
she's like in in a surrounded by guys
who have this kind of cash and so my
point is not so much the Val dollar
value but that in a traditional dating
sense women expecting men to pay and pay
well is the traditional gender role and
arguing that women should either not
expect the men to pay to pay well or to
split is the progressive argument yeah
so if I see like a woman getting all G
Eed up and putting on a ton of makeup
and doing a lot of work and be like I
want a guy who's going to pay then I'm
just like I see nothing wrong with it I
think my issue with it wasn't so much
that the man should be paying cuz I do
think that the man should pay for the
date I think my issue with it was how
direct she was instead of just being
like Oh that was so nice you took me out
for dinner that was really great she was
like I demand it I well
I they're like put a number on it and
she's like you know you could do this
calculation we could did it before the
show you we did it and she's right yeah
like if you're paying for like
Transportation it's dinner it's the
movie it's like maybe something after
whatever I just would like a little also
like anything yeah I mean I don't think
like like look hinge is not adding a
thing as far as I know I'm not on hinge
but they're not adding a point where
it's like here is the price point at
which I am looking for a first date
right this isn't something that people
typically lead off with she she said 200
and my point was Uber ride 30 bucks
dinner 50 60 bucks maybe 70 bucks
depending on how nice you want if you
get alcohol it's more expensive I'm
including alcohol in there because like
if you're going to like your your
average like Diner in New York it's
going to be like 30 bucks 30 or 40 bucks
if you get an appetizer and two Entre
and then boo you're going be like it's
going to be more than that don't you
think I'm thinking like regular diner
for a burger but if you want to get
something nice like a steak New York
though for even a burger New York is
expensive two burgers is going to be
more than 50 bucks well when I would
when I used to live in Brooklyn and I
would take my kid out to a diner and I
end up spending like 60 bucks crazy with
no liquor well okay then so there you go
easily $100 for the meal if you
especially if you get alcohol at 130
with an Uber and a meal we're talking a
nice date we're not talking like you
went to hang out the park and grabed a
burger at a Burger Shack or something
like that and in Miami that's for the
third date in Miami right no for real it
is and so then you want to do a movie
and you got two movie tickets 20 bucks
each plus popcorn and whatever snack
maybe you're not super hungry but you
want a popcorn you're looking another 50
bucks you're at like 150 or whatever
another Uber right after the fact maybe
you got two or three Ubers in there or
or maybe you drive and it's it's less
but still for gas problem parking like
there's all kinds of expenses and then
you want to round off the night with
like going to the lake and like riding a
ferris wheel I'm to I'm choosing totally
generic things I love this place where
we're both in New York and there's a
lake and a ferris wheel I think this is
great I think it's a great dating world
I think you're in Coney Island so now
you're like then that's an even more
expensive no well if you're at at a
diner like like 200 bucks for the Uber
Diner and then you're at Coney Island
and then you're on the ferris wheel yeah
but I'd want a Broadway show see and how
good are those ticket you can spend $200
alone on the tickets oh at least or I
mean what if you're taking her to
Hamilton it's just crazy right and and
so like you can argue the girl's not
worth it but that's your preference the
point is that woman has had has set a
standard by which she wants to date by
and I'm surprised people are like she's
wrong to ask her like she can ask
whatever she she could say I want a
million dollars on my first date look
and then you I'm so sorry you have
priced yourself out of I don't think
we're compatible financially uh the so
the Boston Globe has love letters which
is their advice column and they have a
podcast and they did a whole season on
finances how it affects relationships
but they talk to two I don't know if
they're gen Z or Millennials but young
people uh because it is expensive
especially for men to be dating I mean
it is basically something they have to I
don't know if you set a budget for it
but it's something they have to factor
in if you want to meet a girl and even
if you're just meeting her for a drink
right alcohol is expensive going out is
expensive the transportation is
expensive uh it's it's not to be done
lightly and I don't think it behooves
women to it goes back to what you said
about conservatives being the ones who
would actually take someone out and
spend the money and do the things and
the shival res things well I think it
just doesn't behoove women to say like
oh I shouldn't expect these things like
you're setting a tone for a relationship
and you know I don't think you should
expect a million dollars on the other
hand these things come with a cost let's
uh let's we let's talk about this in the
members only we take questions from the
audience then but let's read some more
Super chats try and get these in neurod
Divergent says request for cast Castle
does Ian have like an evil Damian twin
that's a neocon I think that'd be sweet
that would be cool we did we did a gag
where on Cass Castle Ian did a behind
the scenes where he's actually an actor
go the best line of all time Richard
Nixon that's a guy I'd like to have a
glass of red wine with makes me laugh
every time and then it's like the actor
who plays the in he's like what
motivates me what gets me out of bed in
the morning for this role
money it was just he he Ian's a good
actor he's like trained and he's like he
does a really good job but it was funny
like the bit was everything you think
about Ian is just fabricate he's
actually this like really well-trained
British guy who's like just trying to CH
Channel this this moronic drug addicted
whatever kind of character idea he's
just doing Lawrence Olivier yeah it's
all a bit Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim
I keep seeing a thing you need to
address we only want you to do what's
right I have faith in you for the next
segment please check the volume now are
you saying check the uh Source cuz I
often will have the wrong Source set and
I'll play a video and then the audio
comes out of the wrong feed and I have
to change the source oh maybe maybe we
should just stop yelling maybe they want
us to speak more quietly no no he's
talking about my segments oh okay
because I'll like I'll play a Twitter
video but it's coming from the TV and
not the speakers so you can't hear it
and ah wait got to do it again yeah I'll
check that I'll check your stream back
after I thought they wanted like a Tim
timcast uh ASMR video there a lot of
whis all right let's read some more
weird nug says getting married in one
week would you mind shouting out me Zach
and my fiance Amber shout out to Zach
and Amber congrats on your marriage good
job that's so exciting congratulations
absolutely crossing the line podcast
says the trend of jenzi thinking they
will be able to dodge the draft is very
amusing it's almost worth World War III
to be able to see them go off to
fight dude can you imagine dest because
they refuse to go to to be to be drafted
destroy the world just to spite jenzy
yeah it's the Millennials I can't stand
yeah real yeah you know jenz is pretty
pretty pretty based I think my J made a
a middle parts a thing and I just never
forgive them for that check it out you
guys you found found Ian graph facted I
don't know anything about graphine you
had a week in this chair and you learn
nothing about graphine I know a fact
about graphine Ian really likes graphine
fact fact the hard-hitting journalism
they pay you for I bought that for Ian
for Christmas not that really he never
opened it well no you're not supposed to
you're not supposed to he not se you
don't want you don't want that F I don't
know what I don't really understand the
gags W for cast Castle is like walking
into a room and Ian's doing lines of
graphine it that's awesome it looks like
a toner cartridge ink that's what it
looks like it does it does all right
let's grab a a Super Chat what is this
Pino's helicopter tour says it's a good
thing we did that emergency test I love
the conspiracy theory the conspiracy
theory was that the emergency test was
activating the 5G Nanobots or something
oh nice I just know someone told me to
turn off all of my like government alert
things and whatever else and I still got
it so I think I the Apple iPhone is uh
as soon as you turn it on league with
the government and I'm the first person
to ever think you turn your phone off
the moment you turned it on it it went
off yeah crazy right I couldn't turn off
it also came early because everyone was
trying to avoid it no I think I think
the way it's designed is that if they're
trying to warn you a nuke is coming or
something like that your phone could be
off you turn it on an hour later the the
message comes through you got it no I
mean like it was supposed to go off at
like 2:30 and instead it went off at 215
I'm just saying no matter what everybody
gets it yeah no matter what you do I
don't consent to this they used to do it
on radio and TV remember they would this
is a test of the emergency broadcast
system I like that that's kind of
nostalgic yeah but like that's nostalgic
but nobody has a TV yeah who has TV
running 24/7 anymore I don't personally
no all right hunter killer 86 says the
only bright side of World War II is
zephram Cochran will be able to make a
warp drive in the aftermath and when he
tests it he will initiate first contact
with the Vulcan race and start us on a
path to Starfleet fair
point I learn so much every time I'm
here calinga says Tim I saw your video
about Cassandra earlier if everyone
valued loyalty the way you do the world
would be a much better place Bravo good
sir and uh uh and I will also clarify
too cuz PE people are mad at Cassandra
because she had uh a tweet about a
paraglider from Gaza and she said
impressive but it was before and so
they're trying to act like she tweeted
after when we knew that the paragliders
they just decided they hate her and
that's ridiculous as a Jew let me just
say she's been so nice to me I've never
met anyone that was so nice and she just
wants peace and so and and stress too
because like we're getting these people
being like who's Tim booking now it's
like bro all of our guests are booked
like two months out yeah it's crazy and
yeah so like everybody we've had on the
past week it's because they were already
booked yeah not because we were like hey
look War happened in Israel let's book
these people I don't know are you
supposed to now be like no guys we have
to have way more Jewish people on to
appease the internet like that sounds
way more creepy and discriminatory in my
opinion some dude made a video where
he's like 21% of timcast guests are
Jewish it was like 21.9 he would he
really calculated it which and there's
no way to appease the internet Han clir
no but I found out that we we book
Jewish people at 10 times the national
average maybe we should hire that guy to
do some data analysis on the company
he's he's really into it I'm like man
Cassandra they're accusing her of being
anti-semitic but she she books Jewish
guests at 10 times the national average
I love how we get accused of being
shills for Israel and now they're
criticizing Cassandra for criticizing
Israel and I'm like dude it's so funny
and and some of them are conservatives
too they're they're attacking our
diversity and I don't like it CU
Sandra's booked people who are like very
pro-israel yeah I think we have like
some pretty pro-israel people coming
here this week too s great but they're
booked in advance we didn't book them on
purpose sometimes we get lucky like
we'll book somebody and we'll book like
just a figurative like you know the the
head of the national Bakers Association
on the same day the Bakers are going on
strike and we're like w how did that
happen you know just didn't that happen
with the Crowder and Candace and stuff
whole thing broke down I think we had we
had booked Candace well in advance right
you had booked Candace in advance yeah
that came on because it was the timing
but the Candace one is
like I liked I liked when we had Dan
Lyman on and Elon Musk was at the border
like the hour before and it's like good
we have a border person talking about
the news stuff like that it's cool I did
not schedule uh Elon Musk Tri trip to
the Border all right let's see Cordo Mal
says mad was blindsided by this are they
so inept so convenient that we forget
about Israel's crimes when they get
attacked I have no love for Palestine
but the biases on this show are showing
now I think the issue is we're not
talking about anything beyond what's
literally happening right now cuz I
can't and so for people to come to me
and be like well what about Israel did
this I'm like no idea I don't know what
you're talking about and also like from
what Hamas said like five people knew
about it like L people knew because they
knew it was Happ they would train people
for they train people to do something
they don't tell them what it's for and
then when you go and do it you know
suddenly you're over the border and
you're actually doing it so Arch Phantom
says y'all are so warped tell me this
was Nat Turner wrong to rebel against
the slave masters that's the analogy and
again y'all are warped I will say this
unequivocally that John Brown was a
psychopath and a bad person he was also
a famous abolitionist who is cheered on
by a lot of people the only problem was
he murdered a bunch of people and that's
crazy I understand slavery is bad dude
no question but like I don't know I just
I can't advocate for a dude who gets his
kids whipped up and goes around just
murdering people like just not not the
way you do things
maybe 200 years ago so the issue right
now is if yall are arguing there's
something bad happening between Israel
and palestin and Gaza and the loss of
land and all this stuff it's like what
do we do about it propose a solution and
then I bid you good luck sir that's it
the idea that Hamas is Justified in
killing civilians because they're
slaves no it when people were like it's
an open air prison if if someone was
being held captive as a slave
and they escaped broke their chains ran
full speed away from the plantation and
the first thing they did was they ran up
to some like 20-y old white woman and
just murdered her mercilessly it's like
okay like what I don't understand what
that has to do with fight like escaping
for your freedom yeah whatever Freedom
wasn't the goal it was Revenge right
yeah or or retribution retribution or
war or whatever if if if the slaves
Broke Free and then just started like
murdering a bunch of random people in
and around the areas because they were
part
I talked about this before uh using Game
of Thrones as an analogy daera
stargaryen takes over this city full of
slaves and then she immediately executes
all of the upper class and slave owners
and then they have a scene brilliantly
written where one of the a guy comes in
for an audience with Daenerys and says
my father was a good man who was
fighting to end slavery and you executed
him the the idea of just everyone who is
an oppressor is fair game settlers are
not civilians it's just Insanity it's
insanity
so you're saying we warped bro I tell
you you're warped if you think it was
justified for Hamas to go kill children
and and kill random people driving in
their cars Israel uh uh released footage
to journalists a journalist from unheard
I trust unheard they do a pretty good
job describe these videos in detail I
would have preferred to have seen them
myself so I'll
Reserve absolute judgment saying I take
with a grain of salt do you agree that
Israel puts out fake stuff too just like
Kamas does I don't have any uh recent
examples but I would assume that is 100%
likely that they're putting up fake
information yeah cuz there was that one
picture where there was like a child's
book on the floor and there was blood
and people an analyzed it and said well
blood doesn't look like this when it D
dry pink right yeah so don't know enough
about it and my actually my actual I've
not issued a direct response in that my
one my my response there is there's no
point in in speculating on what you
don't know I I don't understand so when
I saw that photo I didn't tweet about it
why cuz I have no idea and making an
argument without proof I just think is
Fanning the Flames so that's why I I I I
I I'm critical of the argument that
Israel knew in advance and used their
advantage because that kind of innocent
people in Israel were killed and it
shifts the blame on the people who
killed it or or it deflects a tiny bit
like off of the murderers onto well the
government knew about it as if as if it
makes it netanyahu's fault like but
don't you think you owe it to your
objectivity to at least investigate and
see if the Israeli government lied about
it because if they lied about that who
knows what else they Li doesn't it open
up we I did investigate it what more can
you find there's a picture of a book
okay well that's weird next next next
question if they poured fake blood over
it I how do you know what can you do how
do you investigate it well you could say
the same for some of the reports that
you're BL absolutely which is why I said
when unheard put out a statement saying
they saw the videos I take it with a
grain of salt because I've not seen them
myself yeah but when you watch a video
of Hamas soldiers shooting people it's
like is a Sound Stage that was faked I
mean the preponderance of evidence aam's
Razer would suggest just know you're
looking at videos of people who are
cheering for Hamas and screaming ALU
Akbar murdering civilians and there's
videos of this and there is just like
absurd amounts of evidence just uh uh
Justin aash put out a video where he
said his had as direct family members
were killed in an air strike by by by
Israelis you have people who are who are
Jewish saying these are my family
members who are kidnapped and killed in
in in Israel I don't think these people
are lying to me um right that's all
that's all I can say right so my my
point on the Netanyahu thing is people
have actually tried to come out to argue
that
Israel the government knew this was
going to happen and I'm just like what's
the point of speculating on that with
zero evidence even for even Charlie Kirk
I'll criticize Charlie Kirk what's the
point of even saying that it it's an
interesting thought of a POS of of a
possibility with zero evidence suggest
it's true because I don't think there
should be blind loyalty or Blind Faith
to anyone but Jesus Christ and I think I
you know I've been that's not blind
loyalty it's like it's it's blind
loyalty to not question the possibility
that someone did do the wrong thing and
I've been following but no no no no no
no no no questioning Netanyahu with zero
evidence let's play this game did you
know that uh has anyone asked whether or
not the United States actually uh uh
told Hamas to do it I mean let's think
about what's going on in the United
States the distraction now that emerged
fracturing the culture War I mean the
benefits to Joe Biden at a time when his
approval writing was in the gutter
Ukraine was I mean what's the point of
saying anything like that I could
speculate 50 million ways people
benefited and didn't benefit from this
and so all that's happening is Hamas
killed people and they go yeah well I
bet Netanyahu knew has anyone asked that
question and I'm like sure we'll get to
that after we deal with the people who
murdered a bunch of civilians who we
know did it and did it on camera yeah I
just I think it's not one of the
situations where you can just look
through a narrow ly Lind I think it's it
is two parties involved clearly and I've
been following um AF posts on a lot of
this stuff because I can you know look
to them for objective news and I've been
following it and I'm seeing reports out
of Egypt that they gave them a tip and
they said this was going to happen they
said that there was going to be some
kind of an attack there was going to be
something happen well I think that that
gives Israel the fourth knowledge that
okay we may get attacked so let's you
know strengthen our borders let's you
know gear up our defense systems see
this is the isue go it does speak to my
objectivity and you are very biased is
you don't know what the information
Israel gave is you don't know the value
of it you don't know if who was given to
you don't know if it was taken seriously
it's a meaningless news report Israel
may have War may have been warned by
Egypt warned of what did Israel what if
Egypt says we think from from the West
Bank what if Israel said from from the
north from Lebanon what if they said it
may come from Syria we have no idea what
Egypt said we get this vague report that
Egypt said something the quote was
something big well isn't it confirm that
they shut their military down for seven
hours when attack took place but that
those are things we should explore we
shouldn't just say oh well I who says
we're not exploring it it's it's so it's
because it's bad if if Netanyahu stood
oddly by while his fell fellow
countrymen were being slaughtered and
Carnage was being left behind is being
killed at Mass the issue is that that is
made up right what do you mean what is
what is your evidence that Netanyahu
stood down intentionally with for
knowledge to allow this to happen for
political benefit there are reports of
it seven hours what what report seven
hours that the military was given in
order what's the source I'll give it to
you uh you know it's also like it was a
holiday I believe or something cot yeah
cot that's right right yeah I was
thinking about that when we woke up on
October 7th and there was this
horrifying Massacre and the reports were
coming in and I was thinking um Ben
chapiro hadn't said anything Ari Hoffman
who's at the post-millennial who's also
Orthodox he hadn't said anything and I
realized like you know Orthodox Jews
around the world are not going to know
about this until Sunday and I just I
just really turn on the TV and stuff
right yeah you can't do that so I I mean
I just started a I was just praying for
them to be able to withstand this once
they knew and for their families and for
you know I got to read this one this a
good one John John Sarah uh Sarah
sanguinus good name says 51% of
Americans voted for Biden equals America
supports Biden going to World War III
question mark let me break it down for
you 51% of Americans do not support Joe
Biden Joe Biden has uh uh awful support
isn't it like 36 39 it depends on where
you're looking at the aggregate might be
like 41 but let's make the argument that
51% of Americans did vote for Joe Biden
Joe Biden then goes to war in Ukraine
with Russia should Russia be like well
we can't go to war with the United
States because it's their government
doing it not their citizens or is Russia
going to say we are being attacked by
the United States we fully recognize
that not everyone in the United States
wants this to happen and we want to
minimize civilian casualties but we are
currently being attacked so we will
respond that's the point I pulled up the
article by the way um it's the peoples
voice.top
voice. uh it's a webs online uh
according to Jewish pro-life Foundation
leader sicil routman the IDF was given
standown orders both the Army and the
Air Force seven hours to stand down
while those attacks took place and it
was fact checked it says so did they say
that after the attack started yes I mean
during the attack it says during the
Hamas assault that's that seems weird
that's why and and Lauren witzky
reported on as well Netanyahu ordered
the Israeli military to stand down for 7
hours during the Hamas invasion sat down
with Jewish charity leader Sicilia she
has she
report has anyone asked anyone that's in
the IDF if they actually sit down CU
that's like a you know just ask them by
all means I encourage people to
investigate and report on things like
this but forgive me if I don't choose to
use the people's
voice.top
any number of conspiracies as to what
resulted in this going down and so what
we do know is Hamas wants to kill
Israelis uh many in Hamas just I want to
kill all Jews anywhere they're chanting
even the United States from The River To
The Sea they broke in they killed a
bunch of Civilian citizens old people
captured tourists were killed children
were killed and then I don't understand
why there is this C ous argument made
for Netanyahu standing down even from
Charlie Kirk it's it's speculative it
has no direct evidence it has a report
from the people's
voice.top Israeli police or Army and
they're not there 6 hours after this
nightmare started what happened to the
strongest army in the world how come
border crossing wide open something is
very wrong here they got caught off
guard well she's sick the mil I answered
it I gave you aam's Razer but the
military was told to stand down why
caught off guard that's what you want to
believe to be true I don't want to
believe it to I why are you citing why
are you citing a single person who say I
talk to a person my point is I I I I I
don't think an article from a person
I've never heard of is evidence enough
for me to to believe a secuti conspiracy
about the government choosing to stand
down to allow their own citizens to be
massacred to justify War for some reason
well Times of Israel reported that a top
us lawmaker affirmed Cairo warned Israel
days before the onslaught I mean there's
just a hand something big right and do
that mean I'm just saying that this
handful of warnings paired with a 7h
hour halt it just is it's odd and S hour
halt is not proven and a big warning is
vague what you are doing is you are
choosing to interpret two vague things
to your narrative well when an
person inside Israel with connections to
the government says something who well
I'll pull it up for you that's in this
article the guy I just named uh his name
is Cecile routman it's interviewed by
Lauren witzky um he is
a pro-life Foundation leader works in
the go works with the government what
does that mean works with the government
I mean he's a pro-life Foundation leader
so he works with legislators I assumed
to so he's not a he's not so he's not
actually in government the government so
so he's just a guy who so like I work
with the government CU i' I've done a
show with Matt Gates okay so I just
don't know why you would say the idea we
work with local government all the time
on all our business Endeavors we're not
in the government we have no privy
knowledge so then the question becomes
this let's let's assume that the 7- hour
stand on was true now the question is
for what reason was it there you once
again are making the leap that it was an
intentional act to allow the civilians
to be killed with no evidence I'm making
the common sense uh conclusion that
Netanyahu with one of the most
formidable intelligence agencies in the
world there's no chance that he stood by
and let that there's no way they just
missed it there's no way that's amazing
faith in the power of the intell the mad
is revered for their reach and for their
it does it doesn't matter you can have
whatever opinion you want on mad but
none of this is evidence it's just
speculation and so I I take aam's
Razor's approach okay and that is The
Simple Solution tends to be in the
absence of evidence the solution that
makes the least amount of assumptions
tends to be correct that may not be
absolute but uh I argue there's a
tendency towards you will more likely be
correct if you go down that path all the
leaps you've made are meaningless to me
because there's not evidence it's I have
an idea that seems to make sense well it
might make sense but it doesn't mean
it's true well we don't have the facts
yet and folks that are supposed to be
the pioneers of finding the facts are
saying oh well we don't need to find the
facts because obviously there's this
group here who killed a bunch of people
so they're obviously the ones in the
wrong I think that several people could
be complicit here and the same rage that
you share for Hamas that I share with
you I share for for the leaders who
allowed it to happen well you can argue
they allowed it to happen and that they
failed but that's about it they they
failed and they they were complicit is
what my my argument is and I don't think
that without those PE well no it's not
without evidence you don't have any
evidence they were complicit that's
that's just an absurdity I don't have
any evidence that they weren't complicit
this is this is okay I'm we're going to
go to we're going to go to members only
but I'm going to say this this is why I
absolutely hate the subject bro you you
are you are wildly speculating without
proof of anything and you are adamant
you are correct when you are not okay
there is no proof Netanyahu stood down
intentionally to allow his civilians to
be his citizens to be killed for
political benefit I don't think someone
is poised as Charlie Kirk in the
political world would write a tweet and
say hey I'm speculating that Charlie or
that heong I don't think he is I don't
think he is and I don't think I don't
think the iMed I don't think the
immediate lashing that he faced for
saying that also makes it look like he
was wrong but you're you're allowed to
think what you want but my point is you
don't have proof my proof is that
warnings were given days ahead mosad is
the strongest intelligence agency in the
world I think there's a lot of things
that you know I'll tell you what the
warnings were the warnings were that uh
a large pizza party was going to be had
you know how I know that I made it up
like you did I'm I I I think you don't
know what that warning was you've chosen
to you you've chosen a narrative path
without proof I don't I don't do that
it's not it's not true there's been
multiple reports and many many outlets
have reported on those you don't what
the warnings are the the warnings of
what the warning we know that a warning
was given quote something big we don't
know what they were told if Israel was
told hey something Big's coming from
from Lebanon Hezbollah is going to make
a move that's not evidence of a Hamas
attack and we don't know the degree to
which Israel was warned and how how it
means anything if you're going to take
action without a complete picture you
will end up causing harm causing damage
and F and then and then regretting your
actions I don't want to cause damage to
anybody in the whole time this conflict
has gone on I've been saying I want
nothing but peace I want people to stop
killing each other I want civilians and
kids lifeless bodies to stop being
carried in the streets of Gaza and
Israel and that's
fair but if you if you claim that
Netanyahu did it intentionally without
proof you are actually exacerbating the
problem escalating the conflict
Netanyahu has been under corruption
investigation for years now so I nothing
with what's going on it does though when
you have someone who has a track record
of being corrupt I wouldn't put it past
him to stand oddly by while their
country that Trump is under
investigation as well well Israel is a
is a lot more poised to support
Netanyahu especially since he served for
like 16 years and so I just don't see I
don't see them doing that kind of
Injustice I think they're they're
obviously using the government to attack
Trump here because they know he's the
saving grace of our country we've got to
elect him if we're going to sa America I
think that I don't think that's why
they're doing I think they know that
he's a threat to the swamp I think they
know he's a threat to the swamp Okay and
I think he's a threat to this he's a
threat to the establishment and they
know that and that's why they're trying
to throw everything at him so this this
is this is what I refer to as blind
zealotry right you you're saying you
want less conflict and no more dead kids
but then accusing Netanyahu of
intentionally allowing civilians to die
to to justify political conflict and
that is an argument for escalation not
deescalation justify political conflict
how you you are saying that Netanyahu uh
uh you're advancing even Charlie Kirk's
argument I disagree with I think it's
wrong netan intentionally allowed this
to happen through a stand down order
after after being warned by Egypt and
knowing it was coming you're arguing
that he ordered the Army to stand down
to allow a thousand plus Israeli
civilians including children to die and
be taken Hostage to because he was
facing corruption investigations to
benefit himself politically that is an
argument for escalation that is no no
but it absolutely is if if what you are
saying is true retribution Justice if
what you're saying is true that n did
Netanyahu did that it would require an
international on the part of Iran or
other
nations uh move to take that to to
remove yah from Power yeah yeah you're
calling for escalation I'm calling for
justice to be carried out and people who
were complicit in this attack to face
face that Justice okay so so if n was
compit what's the action that should be
taken well they're not registered in the
IC so I they can't I don't know if they
can go to international criminal court
but so a military force should go in
when they violate Geneva conventions
there should be you're calling for a
military action in Israel to remove
their government no no no that's not
what I'm calling for I'm calling for a
tribunal to be for people to come in
answer for their crimes so Nan should be
arrested I think so how do you arrest
who arrests him they're not registered
with the ICC so I don't know but that
doesn't stop me from pointing out the
inconsistencies that but you're saying
someone should go in and stop Netanyahu
yes someone should and that requires use
of force maybe Hamas should do it e i I
think you can actually you think it
should be you guys are all wrong
everyone needs to go Golden Balls be
that's just it like no more
International governments just Golden
Balls if you want to be right you have
to compete I'm
sber we got to go to the members only
we're going to wrap it up here uh follow
the show at Tim Cy you can follow me
personally at timcast do you want to
shout anything out Preston before we go
uh yeah you can find me on Instagram and
Twitter or I guess x uh the Preston para
um and you can find me my patreon link
in my bio on X I'm Han CL brimo I'm a
writer at
timcast.net want to give a shout out to
Brett dvic you guys know him you love
him I uh hung out with him today on pop
culture with danne font and it was great
and I heckled him quite a bit about
getting married so if you want to watch
that go check out their YouTube channel
if you want to follow me personally I'm
on Instagram at hana. you can see One
Singular photo of Theo Von because I
went to his show last night and uh I'm
on uh X HC beralo thank you so much love
you uh I'm at Libby emmans on Twitter
and you can find the great work we're
doing at theost
millennial.age human events.com and I
appreciate Preston for having the
conversation absolutely yeah I was going
to say the same uh thanks for coming in
here appreciate a lot uh I am surge.com
I'm excited for the after show we get to
talk to all you guys and uh see you soon
we will see you all over at
timcast.net
that